oh my god what it's happening
hey 8 45 you know
but it's happening totally welcome to
fat man beyond
uh i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard hey
hello
this ladies and gentlemen represents the
last
fat man beyond of my 40s i know sunday
somebody has a birthday that's right
next time we do the show
i will be half a century old wow
50 years old still dressed like a child
would you get your big boy pants on
that's true still earning a living i
work in short pants like mickey mouse
you do my whole career i appreciate you
in your second half of your career
you got a blazer on like you're going to
work i classed it up well mickey
sometimes wore a jacket as well right
um that's right this is the last uh show
in my 40s man
so gonna get slower from here
this is the last time i'll be in this
bar as a 40
a man in my 40s next time i come in here
i'll be age inappropriate
you're going to start to get the double
arp mail like you can eat off the silver
menu
hey um what's the silver vegan menu like
just mashed potatoes yeah here your
kumquats
some squash easy on your teeth um no man
i'm excited uh
you know [ __ ] the first 50 were
interesting let's let's go for another
50.
one more ride one more ride then he
dropped dead
um no this will be the last time we do
the show uh
before that big milestone i know and
then you're also doing a big big ass
drive-in spectacular spectacular the
drive-in uh is on
the day after my birthday we're doing
august 3rd celebrating on on my actual
birthday we're doing a live stream
uh streaming 50 out 50 years 50
questions
a streaming with kevin smith um the idea
of doing a
50 question q a
like means we may be there all day
i mean i somehow i kind of expected like
a 50
hour like a a live stream as long as
you're fasting
listen i'm the last bite now [ __ ]
stream until i eat again
that would have been smart man because
then i would have been distracted the
whole [ __ ] time right
just yapping my mouth would have been
you know full of words instead of
[ __ ]
i've been yummy i've been to my share of
kevin smith q and a's
and 50 questions could take you a week
yeah
it might take a while when i was i went
to the carnegie hall one
and uh you answered one question for two
and a half hours
imagine you bought a ticket going like
maybe i'll get to ask him a question
one guy did yeah and the question was
like how you doing
buddy sit down okay i'm sitting down
uh that's what i wanted to do for my
50th was uh carnegie hall
but in a better world in a different
timeline
uh where we don't have covid uh that
might have happened and stuff so
uh um unfortunately that may have
stopped but i my age
aging did not no sons time waits for no
man
it doesn't um or man boy
so uh yeah man this would be it this
would be the last time somebody in my
in my thread like i put up a tweet today
and
the tweet was um you know
there's some [ __ ] going on with the
united states postal service
yes horrible [ __ ] and uh i have
you know special affection for the
united states postal service because
that's how i lived as a child my father
worked for the post office
and uh we were postal [ __ ] family and
stuff
so you know mail was always magical
uh to me you know whether it was my
marvel subscriptions coming in or my
bantha tracks coming in from star wars
fan club or
relatives sending you money aunt barbara
gives you 20 bucks and stuff like
you know later on in life ah my my
premiere magazine has arrived
you know subscription service and stuff
like that
uh the many albums that we stole from
the columbia records house
you know all those wonderful mail
members mailing away
star wars had this unlock when you were
a kid collect a few proof of purchases
mail away and we will send you an action
figure man
you waited for that plain brown box to
show up i ate
so much cereal that i didn't want to eat
just to get a kenner action figure
right oh so at the end of the day you
know a
great affection for it for personal
reasons not to mention
it's a great institution of this country
yeah not to mention if something happens
to
the [ __ ] post office then kevin why
did kevin costner make the postman
like the story don't come true it's got
to be the one thing that's going even
after a [ __ ] apocalypse
there's gotta be some dude who's like
we're gonna get the mail delivered and
[ __ ]
um so i put up this tweet going like
this you know breaks my heart like
what can we do and you know a lot of
people were like buy stamps
send all your packages through usps and
stuff like don't use fedex don't use
ups or whatever um one person
explained to me what you know the gop
is doing or what they assess is the
being
done here and stuff in a way as if i
didn't know what was
[ __ ] going on like i can't read the
news myself
but then also said you want to help
kevin stop being so [ __ ] apolitical
and that stopped me in my tracks because
i'm like
i made red state like i made
dogma like where have i ever been
a political like you know just
just raised a bunch of money for the
naacp empowerment
movement like my uh
celebrity show-off charity is uh the
national black justice
coalition if you watch any of my movies
and listen to a single one of my
podcasts
without being overtly political i think
it's very clear
where i stand on things but in case it
needs to be
said i'm pretty [ __ ] liberal
i don't know if anybody knows that but
like
uh it wasn't in my news but uh it's a
hot take
like it's it's you know i'm sure this is
gonna get picked up on good morning
america because
they're like he finally came out and
said it comicbook.com kevin smith
liberal please don't mistake it
that's actually the true story i love
comicbook.com
we were talking about right before the
show somebody who was like
i saw online somebody wrote one of those
nobody
absolutely nobody comicbook.com
kevin smith wiped his ass all caps
comicbook.com is they like me and they
do right
let me tell you something you know
what's kept my self-esteem going through
this lockdown
comicbook.com because they make me feel
relevant
every week you know kevin smith thinks i
feel like
i'm ef hutton what does he have hutton
says yeah
i i'm with bf nania hutton says
all those [ __ ] leaning in um in any
event
um i i i don't mistake
like me not you know
posting the same stuff as
i don't know like judd apatow as like me
being apolitical
um you know i i don't i don't know how
to
i just i've never been that person i i
don't talk about things
that i'm not insanely well versed in
that's why i talk about trivial things
very trivial things you don't need one
more celebrity
you know going like you know what sucks
in this country
um i'm the person uh who who is
you know over here trying to take your
mind off that from time to time when i
can
if you're into that sort of thing but i
i would not consider myself a political
you do you consider me a political um
i don't i don't you know i in in our
conversations and even
on the podcast like it's relatively
clear you know on on what side
of the aisle you fall and that's not to
say republican or democrat it's to say
liberal versus conservative and it's and
and i have always felt
in as long as i've been a journalist
covering entertainment
and then finding some weird ass back way
into a corner of being part of
entertainment
that you know the job of an artist is to
reflect the world around them
and so an artist should be you know if
not incredibly well-versed at least
in touch with their own feelings about
what's happening in order to make art
that reflects the time that they're
living in
true so art by necessity and artists by
necessity
are political they can't be apolitical
because that's the fabric of the world
we live in
and whether or not you just come out and
[ __ ] say it whether there's bumper
stickers in your car whether there's you
know signs in your lawn
oh there are bumper stickers on the car
but they're selling clerks
they're selling jay and silent bob you
know but it's it's
one need not always shout to the rafters
that you
are this or that while still betraying a
sense of
alignment you know you're neutral good
chaotic good sometimes
i also feel like
like who am i converting like
who do you think i'm talking to out here
that needs
like to be won over to some other side
you know what i'm saying
like i i think i i don't i think
i i think we have a pretty liberal
audience as well we do but
you would know better than me you know
your take it was
the most interesting thing happened like
five years ago
when we put up cameras you know because
for the first two years of this podcast
it was audio only
and nobody knew what i looked like right
and you know then it was oh
[ __ ] mark is black that's right because
i was never like
for the listener at home who cannot see
mark is black and then we started the
show
fyi this is brought to you by grant from
the helena rubin
and also the other one
but so when when that bit of very
closely held information was released
seeing the response from the audience
was fascinating because there were some
people who just
literally didn't know and didn't care
and there were some people who might
have cared if they had known earlier
but were now pot committed is that right
yeah some people are like
listen i would hate on his ass but uh he
writes a good story
yeah like you know some [ __ ] about the
same [ __ ] that i know about so i guess
he's cool
so in that way you might have been a
bridge you know it it
and lots of them told me that is that
right you know especially when we
started
covering things like luke cage and iron
fist and black panther
and just that idea that there was a
perspective that had never been part of
their lives right
that suddenly is and they can you know
recalibrate the way they view the rest
of the world
you know and then when we talked about
you know black lives matter stuff and
being able to
to use the commonality the the lingua
franca of nerd
as this sort of ambassadorship from
people who might not feel the way i feel
about things
at least we had that common tongue that
we can talk truth is
and so it's it's not a political thing
but it is
oh you come from a different place and
you might believe different things
simply from your upbringing not that you
have chosen to believe one thing or
another
but people have been very warm like 80
90 of this audience has been incredibly
fluid
with their belief systems as it relates
to sort of race and class in america
just i didn't think about it that way
before i don't have any black friends
you're my one black friend
okay is that what they say every now and
again
like you're the one black guy that i
know i'm sorry
somebody said that's me i'd be like
you're in trouble because
i hate to break this too yeah so like
you know while i don't think this
podcast is
by nature political i think that
by virtue of the pair of us talking
about [ __ ] every week
our our our feelings are not secrets
agreed
you know and it's not a bad thing no
it's not a bad thing at all
um and also we should totally save the
poster post service
i mean which is what the original point
of the discussion was before i got taken
down the rabbit hole of like
political um i mean and i'm not even
saying save it for sentimental reasons
it's like
how the [ __ ] does the post office go
under neither
rain nor sleet nor snow dead of night
nor
dead yeah and now it's like
slow that package down would you it's
going too fast yeah
i mean the fact that you can for less
than a dollar
send something across the country and
believe with 100 surety that it will get
there within a week
is a miracle yeah like and this happened
before
[ __ ] jets and planes and email and
stuff like
you could actually just and and the fact
that you could connect the country in
some cases the world
for less than it cost to buy a bag of
chips
like it's miraculous and the fact that
that's not a thing that that the
government is
is rallying the wagons to protect
boggles the mind
except for the fact that we know why
it's not rallying to protect it
because you know lots of people vote by
mail
and if which is [ __ ] nuts man like if
that's the case if the post office is
going down
because of that that's
yeah i mean john oliver had an amazing
yeah i remember that piece
yeah where it's like here's here's what
the post-service
proposal was supposed to do and how it's
supposed to work and here's the
legislation that got introduced
you know five six years ago that you
know cut it out by the knees and here's
the new [ __ ] that's happened in the last
three or four years
that has made it untenable and there's
no way for it to to
make a profit it was also not designed
to make a profit it's true
this is like what do they call it like a
civil service is it a civil servant
public good yes
um i'm sorry we're probably way off the
[ __ ] rails here jc
what is it what's going on like in the
chat is everybody like what the [ __ ]
i liked you better when you were a
political yeah in your effort to be
apolitical you become very political
people are pretty civil people are doing
okay good
excellent thanks kids but yeah thanks
for allowing us a little bit
and it did that john oliver 50 year old
man talk
let me tell you about the mail uh that
john oliver piece was also like the tail
end of he's like yeah well we bought
stamps and
it turns out that you can put your face
on stamps and if people buy it then it
goes
back to the [ __ ] post office and it's
like
hey we should do smodcast
i'm in can you still do them i believe
so um my friend derek
who was the video assist artist on um
on uh jane salem bob reboot
out in new orleans uh playback guy so
every after every take i'd be like derek
and then he would start playing the take
because when you're in the movie and
directing the movie there's a lot of i'm
here and now i run over here to watch it
now i run over here to pretend
so uh he sent me recently
a bunch of beautiful letter about
working on the movie but a bunch of
stamps
um that had me and jay on them harley on
them
me and jen on them and stuff and he was
like they're legit stamps you could
actually use them and stuff
uh so i i didn't know if there was some
sort of cut off because i remember the
john oliver piece there was some sort of
like
deadline or something like that but if
we can i would totally do that that'd be
fun
and people would buy them and use the
post office
um you wouldn't even have to put them on
letters man you just put them on your
binders your trapper keepers that you
hold like this while you walk down the
hallway
your favorite smodco podcasters
a trapper keepers
b always yeah jews schools
schools books close people this is
non-social discipline
um we've got uh a bunch to talk about
including
um you know uh
i i found a quibby show that you would
love
did not see this coming yes hold on it
was the big news of the week for me
um i went did you subscribe to the
quibby i went and
i do now because i went and did a
voiceover for a show they got
the russo brothers produced or ap
executive produced a show called
slugfest
which is based on a book which is about
the history of competition between
marvel and dc
wow so you know these are
eight minute episodes they had 10
that i got to watch that were [ __ ]
spellbinding like i i'm not
over or underselling it anybody who
enjoys this show
would enjoy that show 10 000 times more
they deep dive it's true i'm just being
honest they deep dive for eight minutes
mind you
on like legit epic moments
in comic book history so not just the
like
you know uh old marvel old dc you know
the from the cross over to timely and
stuff
i'm talking about they did an
eight-minute deep dive on the clone
saga jeez it was [ __ ] wonderful
and on top of it so it's this
documentary series and you know how
documentaries do reenactments
they get [ __ ] famous people to do the
reenactments
so like uh at one point ray wise you
know who played uh
he was in of course twin peaks many
things but he i know him
i worked with him on reaper he was our
devil and reaper
he played jack kirby it when jack kirby
left marvel and went to dc that's
perfect
it was [ __ ] uncanny they had a few
people
playing stan including a younger person
when he was stanley uh and he was
working for
um oh god who was it the two cats who
created captain america
joe simon and jack kirby joe simon and
jack kirby are sharing an office and
it's a different
person playing that version of jack
kirby because it's younger
and at one point like they they they've
put out
captain america they tell the story of
of joe
and jack working at timely
and you know they'd had some complex
success with the human torch
and submariner but superman was
[ __ ] huge and so they were like
we need a superman and so they're
sitting around trying to
come up with the ideas and finally
they're like
captain america and so they start
building the character
joe simon is played by um
um oh [ __ ] i'm such a stoner
brandon um who played superman oh
brandon ralph
yes brandon ralph is playing joe simon
and it's it's like wonderful at one
point he references superman and you're
like that guy played superman
um the lady who is in deadpool who plays
his girlfriend
marina she plays
jeanette kahn wow at
dc comics because they do an
eight-minute deep dive on
when jeanette was hired in the 70s not
only the first like [ __ ] female
executive
in publishing or at least in comics um
but like how
they do a story on the dc explosion
remember that
so in this like 70s at one point dc was
like we're going to add a bunch of
[ __ ] titles it was like the
nhl expansion league where suddenly they
were like
here's [ __ ] way more teams than you
ever had front camera please
um so at that point they
introduced [ __ ] dead man they
introduced like a bunch of
[ __ ] characters stuff that still
plays today
but you know the books went right in the
[ __ ] and the dc
explosion instantly became the dc
implosion
and they cancelled 60 of their [ __ ]
runs and stuff
which led them to some other thing that
like made them succeed or something like
that i think was the moral of the story
i just couldn't believe they were doing
a whole [ __ ] deep dive on like
jeanette khan
like that's crazy like um but it also
makes sense
what else did they do uh workout video
in there for which one anyone it seemed
like the quibby guys were all about
those workout videos
nothing about working out they uh that
they're just cats
she that was katzenberger he was the one
who was offering gal gadot
um what else did they do they did
the uh death of robin the call-in
um and that was dramatized like
it's [ __ ] stunning like a stunning
achievement is directed by the kids that
directed
um batman and bill the documentary about
bill finger bill finger the bill finger
dock um
and uh it is just
[ __ ] perfection like i i had such a
it wasn't even like they were like would
you wanna
like throw a voice in here i i like i
was like are you [ __ ] i'd be
mad now that i've watched them all if i
wasn't
[ __ ] involved like it's so so [ __ ]
good i was like jesus man
like when does this happen so
look out for it's called slugfest did
you have to watch the screeners on your
phone
i did watch them on my phone and never
once occurred to me to like do this [ __ ]
but they gave me a link
but honestly after i watched him i was
like this is quibby and i downloaded
[ __ ] quibby
wow cause it was good i was like this is
[ __ ] tight like
all that it took for them to get a
subscriber to quibby was to pay you a
god
godly ransom to voice over a thing
like 28 times what it'll cause you to
subscribe
all they had to do was show me a show
where i was like oh [ __ ] i like this
phone you're doing this
yeah so it's cool at one point
apparently they reached out to me to be
like on it on one of the reenactments
like i could have played howard mackey
i'm not sure who it was man it might
have been because instead they got
anthony mackie
would be amazing because him and i
compete for the same jobs all the time
it's the goatee uh bobby moynihan i
think they got it
so you know i guess like we were off
doing the reboot roadshow tour
so to kind of get in there as as
anything was kind of cool but i'm
telling you
you will absolutely [ __ ] love it it
was like it was made exactly
for us because it's not just
like they like it's they talk about
when kirby created the new gods of dc
and brought in like funky flash men
who was like a big poke stan
and how like jack at one point in his
life was like maybe i went too far with
that because apparently like really
hurts stan's feelings and stuff um
it's so dishy and just wonderfully
[ __ ] rendered man
um they tell a story about how
stan just imagine stan lee
recreates the dc universe how that
happened
they do like an eight [ __ ] minute
deep dive on that it's crazy and now the
sky's the limit if they get picked up
they could literally like just pick an
obscure story
like or any or a well-known story they
did of course
the death of superman and why they did
this death of superman which
like they were doing the superman is
going to
marry lois that's what they work toward
and then jeannette khan came in and was
like the tv show
lois and clark they don't want them
getting married because they're not
married on the tv show they're [ __ ]
there's chemistry but
marriage would be weird so they had to
put aside
the marriage storyline which they built
for like six months louise simonson was
interviewed
and then somebody plays louise simonson
wow
um in in the oh it was what's her name
um the girl who played supergirl's mom
on the show and the pilot and like for
the first season
wow she's always on the colbert show she
does the first lady
um yes
she played louise simonson and then they
also interview
louise simonson and they talk about how
after they built that storyline about
like superman lois finally gonna get
married after [ __ ] decades
like they had to change on a dime
because the [ __ ] show
and out of frustration um
i forget who it was the guy goes let's
just kill him
about superman and they were like you
know what
like that's mike carlin was that him it
wasn't mike though because he was the
editor of the group
this was like a group meeting it was
another famous name i think it was one
of the
writers on the book but not the writer
but i forget his name but i remember
louise simonson because i was like oh
[ __ ] man she was there for
grounds and she told the story about
like you know he said let's kill him
let's just kill him
and then they did the death of superman
storyline which
made them so much [ __ ] money
like still one of the biggest selling
comic books of all time
and like reintroduced superman remember
everybody was gonna buy those
[ __ ] like i'm gonna buy like they
show this
recreation of like louise simonson
talking to a friend and a friend is like
you know we just bought
20 more issues of that death of superman
because we're going to send the kid to
college
and laura benanti as as uh louise
simonson is eating a cookie
and she's just like oh god oh really
yeah and she's like choking on her
cookie because she doesn't want she's
because
louise simon said she says she's like
you know
basically when you think about it if
there are millions of something
it's not really going to be worth
anything she's like so all those people
that were like oh my god he dies in this
issue this is historic
never put together that like it's
[ __ ] 10 million of these books in
existence so
how on earth is it ever going to be as
popular as action comics number one
yeah nothing is rare when everybody has
it when everybody's got one
so i'm telling you man i've i've that
was my favorite thing i did
all week in the last week of my 40s was
watch that show cause
i went into it going like all right i'm
sure this will be fine and like
it was a page-turner man i was like oh
my god oh my god i can't believe oh my
god they're doing this oh my god they
did this story
i hope they go again man it was it's
[ __ ] dope uh you
slug slugfest based on the book and the
guy that wrote the book
he's one of the people interviewed yeah
michael he gets interviewed an awful lot
um once again we've sold a tv show
better than the people whose job it is
to sell a tv show
true nobody knows about it yet i think
but this i might actually be the first
time i don't even know if they
like in the trades did you just announce
it
we might have we got real news you guys
that's true uh maybe there must have
been
some announcements somewhere along the
way reason to subscribe to quibby
slugfest get it get it i'm telling you
it it's it
is it was it was that [ __ ] good
i look forward to the uh the image
founders episode
they didn't do that and i was surprised
but they also didn't do a lot of obvious
things
but at the same time did [ __ ] where i
was like what they do this one great
story
did you ever hear this there was this
guy named tom
fagan who was like the king of cosplay
he kind of introduced cosplay
he had this there's this town in vermont
where he had this
superhero parade once a year and
he put floats together and all these
people and this is in the 70s like 1974
or some says [ __ ]
and they got pictures all these people
dressed up like
[ __ ] comic book heroes so you got
like an ant-man
like circa 1973 not just spider-man and
[ __ ]
it's like honestly early proto cosplay
it is cosplay it's just no
and it's kind of a convention like
before there was a convention
so this guy would bring together marvel
and dc writers you know they were always
like oh we don't like each other but
they all [ __ ] hung out together and
stuff
and so um who is it um
the guys that did batman in the 70s
marshall rogers and uh
oh man you know god damn it it's not
denny
right not danny but
ah he also did doctor strange
oh [ __ ] damn it and we
host a [ __ ] show about comic books
this is just me being a stoner i totally
smoked his name away
can you google real quick um
oh [ __ ] how do we track him down um what
did i say
uh marshall rogers batman
and then it'll be the other name
that's usually associated with that
either that or it's flat out marshall
rogers and i've really
just there's an artist though right
was it englehart an artist then maybe it
is what is the martial what does it say
about marsha rogers
say he's a comic book writer was an
american comic book artist best known
for his work at marvel and dc
that's who marvel that's who marshall
rogers was
yes now click on steve englehart
that's the guy he did the batman run
with
wow look at that i mean eating up time
uh steve engelhard
like american free show he's an american
writer of comic books and novels
he is best known for his work at marvel
and dc in the 70s and 80s
yes pseudonyms include john harkness and
cliff
garnett and we're looking for
did he work on doctor strange
potent run on doctor strange originally
with frank brunner
in which strange's mentor the ancient
one died and strange became the new
disciples
supreme they've been talking about that
all right so what's his name
steven steve englehart um all due
respect sorry i smoked that away
i should know better um steve englehart
gives this amazing [ __ ]
interview where he talks about like look
it was the 70s like
we all did drugs he's gone so that wound
up
in the [ __ ] work so he talks about
he's like that's
like why doctor strange became the
saucer supreme he was a master of the
mystic arts but we were like
no he needs to be the sorcerer supreme
and they started writing these trippy
[ __ ] stories and
they turned in it's so well dramatized
as well
they because they have the guy telling
the real story and then they reenacted
they turned in this story where
doctor strange like meets essentially
god
and you know stan was like i don't need
religious people
down on me and stuff so he got a letter
stand from this priest this reverend
blah blah somewhere
and he said hey man i read that issue
and like
that's that's what i'm talking about
that's a representation
like this is something you can give to
kids a powerful story
with morals and blah blah blah and stan
was like blown away because stan
read all the letters that came in like
he was he was voracious they every one
of them says it
like they're like stan and the letters
that was his thing he believed in
listening to the audience
so he brought this letter around to
everybody because he was talking about
killing the storyline
and then he was like look this came from
this reverend guy
and he's saying he's using this in his
church to like teach kids so whatever
you're doing
keep doing it maybe i should try some of
that lsd they have them saying
and it's sean gunn plays stan oh nice
at that age so then they cut to steve
engelhardt going we wrote the letter
we sent this letter to stanx we knew he
read the letters
and we knew he was very impressionable
so we wrote this glowing letter of the
book
from a religious person that he was
worried about and then everything went
fine he's like
we knew nothing was going to come from
the comic book stan was just being a bit
alarmist so
we just kind of assuaged the situation
it's a beautiful story but the key of
the story is
they created the first crossover event
in between dc and marvel because
they wrote themselves into a story that
spanned two marvel comics and one dc
comic
the same characters that crossed over so
the same cats that met like the hulk
these three hippie dudes were in batman
or whatever [ __ ] issue whatever comic
dc comic
it was a few weeks later
like they did it on the down low they
never told their bosses
and when their bosses got wind of it
they were like just don't do it again
uh but it was the secret dc marvel
crossover
that story alone i was like i didn't
[ __ ] notice [ __ ] and i didn't know
about this dude tom fagan
like that's that's like kind of legit
and also
this story is brought to you by the
united states postal service
that's right good point the whole reason
we started talking about this [ __ ]
in the first place save the post office
damn do it
oh my stan wouldn't have gotten amazing
self written letters
to justify dr strange talking to god
he's got a point way to tie it
that really ties the room together
lebowski well done
um all right shall we dive into the news
we can dive into some news my friend
um i you know this bottle
empty but green
segway i'm in the news this week
i'm the captain now you are you are the
top of the news my friend
um do i have the top story you have the
top [ __ ] you're so sweet mark bernard
and he's used to be a newshound so he
pulls the news
together every [ __ ] week right here
at the scum and villainy cantina
um this week i make the news
you do uh in my role as the podcast sam
eagle uh i'm going to read the news
please uh the first item kev's green
hornet news
yes i figured i didn't have to like dial
up the headline
no way given that uh that you were what
do you hear about this new project
i hear that new project i hear that the
uh
the the yoga hoses filmmakers teamed up
with kids producer wild brain
they led with that oh my god maybe leave
with the yoghos we're [ __ ]
and i led with yoga hoses just that's
just tickled me thank you
uh to develop with kids produce a wild
brain to develop a new series based on
green hornet yes the classic superhero
franchise this is true
smith has long been a fan of the green
hornet in 2004 he was hired to write a
feature film
based on the character from miramax that
project never materialized um
but filmmaker got scared yeah
very much so true story uh one day i was
like
the [ __ ] man it came after a meeting i
was in a meeting at miramax in los
angeles um with the
great person that ran uh they're they
were trying to like start up
marketing division not marketing they
were always good at marketing like
merchandise like bringing in product
placement corporate sponsor
[ __ ] like that so you know you're doing
the green hornet
guess what every car company is like we
want to be the black beauty
so she set up these meetings one day
where i met with the toy companies i met
with the car companies
i met with uh the united states air
force or
navy the one that has a hornet jet
so there was a military man who came in
explained to me all the capabilities the
horner jet we can shoot with it anytime
we want and
we were like but ours is a green horn
he's like we can paint it yeah and also
ours is a car
[Laughter]
it could be a channel but it's like i
don't know if you know this story but
you know black beauty's car um and i got
i remember at the end of the day i was
like
i haven't written a [ __ ] word there's
no script and we're
having meetings about toys and [ __ ] i
was like this don't feel
right to me um and and so i
spoke to the then chairman of miramax
who shall remain
he who shall not be named um he's in
jail somewhere voldemort
voldemort himself and i was like i don't
want to do this anymore i said
thank you for the job but like i don't
think i have the chops to
to make this movie i certainly don't
want to direct i don't want to spend
75 million dollars on something that
wasn't my idea
you know what i'm saying like if it's if
i'm ever going to spend that much money
i
hope it's on something i come up with
because then at least i can stand behind
that but like
i don't think i'm the guy and then he
suggested just write it
and i was like all right then i wrote it
and handed it in and at one point
john woo was gonna do it which was kind
of exciting
much better choice for director if i do
say
so my damn self um and then the
uh the weinsteins left miramax to create
the weinstein company
guys a lot of use the w word man it's
[ __ ] it's a little harsh on a
thursday night you know but it's like
it's it's history you gotta use the
words
of history um so uh that
script was left behind at uh at
disney which owned miramax at that point
um over at uh dynamite comics they
wanted to do
an adaptation uh and so they got the
script
from the trendle estate disney gave
permission said go ahead
but i couldn't get paid to do it to for
the comic book like he got paid already
i was like best favor uh and then uh
phil hester broke down my script and
jonathan lau did a gorgeous [ __ ] run
on the book and
i would come in and re-dialogue because
my script was like real old and [ __ ]
um and that i thought was it i was like
that's you know
that's then seth rogen made the movie um
now there's a new movie that's coming
sooner or later at universal
so i thought that was you know i did the
book with ralph
batman the green hornet but that was you
know the 60s one that was definitely
ralph driven project
so i really thought that you know i'd
cross
paths with green hornet and the cato uh
of
team for the last time and you know
professionally and yet
the good folks at wild brain reached out
to me and they're like we're gonna do
like a cartoon and i was like it so
happens that i have some cartoon
experience
now funny how the world has led me oh my
god and i had such a good time doing
masters of the universe i was like i can
get my head around this
so i've seen like the designs uh they
didn't release any of the imagery yet
and it is
it's it's beautiful it's gorgeous it's
very
california california sunset
is it period this book it is quasi
period yeah i i can't say it's quasi uh
period we're going for a
well naturally being a big [ __ ] fan
uh
there's one cartoon that i want to
emulate and that's batman the animated
series
uh we don't have as many cool ass rogues
uh but
that's still for me the gold bar you
know the gold bar
the high bar whatever gold standard
that's thank you um
of uh of of storytelling uh
animated storytelling superhero animated
story telling whatever you want to call
it
some people will be like green orange
it's not a superhero i understand um
so i i'm technically neither is batman
yeah it's true
just a hero actually and actually like
they're both vigilantes
but one pretends he's a criminal
whereas the other is just thought to be
a wrongly a criminal which is so weird
it's always weird when they're like
the batman friend or foe it's like the
[ __ ] do you mean
how much more good can he do before
you're like friend clearly friend
well unless you talk to those kids who
are at the uh the wayne manor christmas
party
i was like man remember that's enough
over the years
you guys talking about batman's leg you
guys talking about batman yeah
oh he hit my cousin in the face so hard
he broke my nose
well clearly you were doing something
wrong no i wasn't i was just walking
across the street
uh melissa villa senor at the end she's
like you talking about the batman
she's like my cousin tell me the joker's
gonna cut off his wiener
bruce wayne's like what um
yes uh wait what were we talking about
uh friend or foe friend or foe yes green
hornet
is the guy that pretends to be the bad
guy he's like i'm a gangster
with a mask um and so he takes down
criminals from the inside and stuff
uh so yeah i don't know if
so you're gonna do that whole like i
guess it's not a superhero
right but he's a hero yeah he's a hero
but like that
if it's modeled after batman the
animated series which was
oh we have helicopters and and like
fat ass cars they had blimps as well and
there's no cell phones
and like the weird we're kind of
existing
in this weird mishmash of noir tropes
that could be cool it's uh it's
primarily
aimed at kids whereas
you've worked on masters of the universe
with me
that didn't never i mean it works for
kids but
we weren't that wasn't the aim that
wasn't the
audience we were recording and that was
right but i think that
you know i i've i've been doing a very
really deep dive
into both the clone wars and i've been
re-watching avatar the last airbender
which you know
both of which you know supposedly made
for kids
supposedly made for kids and still
totally legitimate for kids like it does
a bunch of [ __ ] that feels very
kid-centric
but the themes and the plot and the
character moves beneath it
are they're just good story and it
doesn't seem as if good story has an age
requirement or age limit good point you
know and so that's what i responded to
about batman the animated series just
good story after good story like you
could be 10 years old and watch batman
series
and get everything you wanted from it
and you could be [ __ ]
30 and just like i got everything i
wanted from this because i got
[ __ ] you know heart of ice that's the
key that's the model right there
and i you know technically they were
courting eight to twelve
like that's the i think that was the
target for batman the animated series
i don't think with masters we didn't
target eight to twelve
at all we actually just did the next
episode of the show
um but hornet is is very much in
eight to twelve so i'm in a
a um it feels like batman the animated
series for many
reasons is the obvious role model
except you know we're not going to be as
dark like they had
darkness was their co-star you know
ours is like eternal sunset nice
yeah yeah there was this um i think dc
dc nation maybe they had a bunch of
animated shorts i wanna say like five or
ten years ago
yeah yeah and there was one amazing one
i think it was directed by a guy named
robert
valley valet which was wonder woman and
it was like wonder woman
like miami vice style in a weird way
and so like she drove this big ass
muscle car instead of the invisible jet
but it was invisible because it's super
cool
right but it was that kind of eternal
sunset like everything was reds and
yellows and browns and she was like
screaming up at the beach and she
stepped out with
like big-ass platform shoes and like
this is
gorgeous yeah this is like and and to
get to play like hawaii 5-0
or like rockford files but with black
beauty and green hornet and cato
you're going to have so much fun i know
right i remember that dc nation thing
they did
they did a green arrow short with
onometopeia bots where he was fighting
anametopia bots and then at the end
they beat the last one and onomatopoeia
dropped out it's a character like that i
created that was in this cartoon it was
one of the most
rewarding moments of my entire career i
didn't know it was coming nobody
said hey they're going to use that
character and [ __ ] i was like
[Music]
um so yes green hornet and cato man
coming at some point give me good times
i'll give you more details
uh when i know more but thank you to the
good folks at wild brain for
thinking of me they also have the
peanuts they used to be dhx remember dhs
oh yeah
they changed their name to wild brain
didn't they also do inspector gadget
like back in the day
how do you pronounce it caillou uh they
also own
one of my favorite franchises in the
world the degrassi franchise
oh now you see my long long play here
now you see the long con going on i'll
give you i'll give you a green hornet
you got to give me something in return i
may never ask you for a favor but if i
do
do you think though there's something
innately wrong about that
me like willing to take over or trying
to
like even thinking of is there something
sacrilegious about an american talking
about
taking over degrassi you know what i'm
saying shouldn't that be in the hands of
a canadian
i mean the the way to do it would be to
partner with a canadian to find a good
canuck it's cover
for when the uh the pc police show well
i can't do it now that you literally
called it for what it is get one of them
canadian beards man
you know just say they're working but
they put them in a closet
dab a little maple syrup on his ears and
send them out chum the waters
go be extra canadian now i'm really not
getting the job [ __ ]
um yeah they own that as well so
wonderful company man
and it was real nice that they were like
yeah come on play again so
it'll be fun man it's you know as a big
batman the animated series fan
it's nice to be able to and you can do
the thing that the green hornet never
really did which is
give him the rogues gallery yes like
that's that would be instead
all of that [ __ ] that's what i said i
was like oh my god like and of course
once we find a home then they're like
here's all the money and stuff to make
the show
that's when i start calling all my
[ __ ] friends and be like write a
script
write a script write a script come here
let's make up some bad guys yes exactly
man
but then be smarter than those [ __ ]
old-timers who would make up cool
characters and not get any money for
them
be one of those cats who's like oh i'll
make up a [ __ ] character
yes here's my character payment i'll
tell you what i'm not even gonna pay you
i'm just gonna steal that [ __ ]
cinderella idea
that you just put out there for the
[ __ ] world i'm gonna do that's gonna
be my whole green hornet
pitch they're gonna be like this sounds
more like cinderella i was like it is
but that's only because it's such a good
idea and nobody's doing it yet we got to
do it fast we're going to shave the
serial numbers off this and it's ours
so green hornet man uh let's roll
cato as they used to say on the show is
that going to be the ad
campaign let's roll kato i don't know
like do you really want to use
like the ad campaign from the 60s for 8
to 12 year old audience in 2021
22 they'd be like what's the reference
yeah what does that mean
i don't understand these words i mean i
hate to be this guy but didn't they say
like uh
during september 11th weren't they like
let's roll or something like that i
believe they did i think those were the
words but those were
the good guys yeah totally yeah well and
i mean
i'm not making any comparisons here but
green hornet is
a good guy a good guy but it just feels
like
the short answer mark i'm going to lose
this job based on this kind of thing
the short answer mark is no i doubt that
will be the market campaign tomorrow's
news
wow that was fast
comes then they goes who's the guy who
got who was in the
the trump spokesman for like [ __ ] a
week oh yeah scaramucci
it looks like it's i could scare
moochies out of this [ __ ] green
oregano became its own uh
in sort of modicum of time like how many
scaramouches is this
secretary he didn't even make it a
quarter scaramucci
all right that's my news that's your
news and that's the show goodnight
everyone
we have a lot more news that doesn't
involve me i have much
more news what's next uh the emmy
nominations came out
this past week did you get any um i got
none
were you working on anything that was up
for something um
i worked on the second season of
carnival row
the first season of which was nominated
for best title sequence
and best theme song huh
yes a lot of categories in these emmys
who knew
um what about picard do they get
nominated for anything um
no they mounted a very aggressive uh for
your consideration campaign and they
didn't
they didn't even get him one and they
didn't get him one the [ __ ]
yeah um all right who did get nominated
let me guess
better be [ __ ] watchman watchman amen
then there's still some justice in this
sick old world and when i say sick i
mean literally there's a [ __ ] virus
going around i don't know if you read
the news
yeah no it's it's still happening it's a
sickle world um yeah it got the single
most nominations of any television show
oh that [ __ ] rocks
it is so unbelievable good i just
rewatched this morning
the uh you know [ __ ] dr manhattan
gets captured episode
where he's like watch the eggs it's such
a clever moment because he's literally
saying it to her but
he's saying it to the audience watch the
eggs so well written yeah i feel like
they were smart to walk away [ __ ] trying
to top that yeah i mean i did see a
quote from damon
uh i think it was today or yesterday
because he's doing a bunch of press
rounds because it gets
you know nominated what's the quote
what's the quote like uh maybe i got a
good idea
no the quote is uh i always imagined
this continuing
but you know and would i like to have
done it sure but the thing about
this process was i loved it because of
the people i was doing it with
and they have all sent scattered to the
winds it's like there's no way to bring
this band back together
and without them i can't imagine doing
this again but i would absolutely love
to see what somebody else does with this
universe in the same way that i picked
it up
and fashioned something interesting from
it i would love it if somebody else
down the road picks up this book or this
show and find something new
i mean technically they could true
detective this [ __ ] right where they get
some
other creative team but like that's a
high [ __ ] bar to clear
it really is i mean god damn it that's
some perfect [ __ ] television and it's
based on some [ __ ] that years ago
you get beat up for liking people
dismiss you for liking now it's so
[ __ ] ensconced in the culture
is probably going to walk away with a
bunch of emmys i hope it gets them all
yeah it was nominated for 26 nominations
across 19 categories including
outstanding limited series of sending
writing for a limited series wow
um and nods for jeremy irons regina king
and uh and i think louis gossett jr
yaya abdullah mateen ii
and uh depo what about jean smart
gene smart got best uh supporting
actress did she good because she was
[ __ ]
wonderful in it she's great one of my
favorite moments of uh
god was that last year already when did
that end
right before yeah god tail end of 2019
right before the year turned um
in other words 48 years ago when she's
the yeah [ __ ]
75 years ago it's been 83 years
um the uh it's still one of my favorite
moments and it is
when she's in the final episode she's
back on her chair
and he's like miss gizette miss just bet
what is it miss
just just back just betchik yeah
he's like what a what a pleasant
surprise oh god that was so [ __ ] good
it delivered on every level not just
like holy [ __ ] i love the watchmen
um it just delivered even if it wasn't
the watchman that [ __ ] would have
worked
yeah i mean the trick of it is that you
know and damon talked about this a lot
including on the podcast that i recorded
with him is that his way into it was
finding what
what was the thing plaguing america at
the time
you know and when when alan moore first
wrote it it was
kind of totalitarian governments and it
was margaret thatcher and it was
you know it was it was this whole sense
of
conspiracies and overriding political
shenanigans
and for damon it was race in america
like that's
that's that's the issue that if we're
not talking about we should be talking
about
and so it's finding that next thing that
will be
both harmonious with those two previous
incarnations but
then its own its own special perfect gem
of a formula to follow and i don't know
what that is i don't know if damon knows
what that is
but some brilliant ass person oh
they better make sure it's [ __ ]
brilliant before they step up to that
plate again
i mean it's a bold game to be like you
know the watchmen
we're doing a sequel like what and they
[ __ ] did it they knocked out the park
special [ __ ] yeah give them give all the
awards who else
um the mandalorian oh this was exciting
too man exciting it got like best drama
or something right yes
drama it's [ __ ] phenomenal an
outstanding show is
[ __ ] amazing outstanding guest actor
for giancarlo esposito
for really yeah that's pretty dope man i
mean he was in like what two episodes
yeah he's like as a guest he's in it for
like 15 minutes he was great and
memorable
very much so um and of course an
outstanding visual effects category wait
is he the only acting one
um i believe he is let me double check
they didn't give one to
pedro no i don't think they did i mean
technically it's like
how much of how much of it was pedro you
know what i mean it's pedro's voice
don't get me wrong but like
i read that sometimes you know they were
shooting without them and some dude just
wearing a suit right
yeah so and that's no big secret i think
that's part of it that's out there
it's out there so i guess it would be
tough to i mean outstanding voice
performance by an actor
um but yeah so and and stranger things
and yet at the same time taika ytt got
nominated for ig 11. yeah so
technically pedro could have been
[ __ ] nominated
um how weird is that crazy weird but
honestly i got no problem with it that
performance is pretty amazing
it's really touching like when he
[ __ ] comes back and he's like i am
also
a nurse oh [ __ ] that's a great show how
many nominations
um mandalorian mendo let me see
it makes me want to watch that show
again baby yo to get a nomination
um well outstanding visual effects so
yeah
technically that qualifies um 13
categories so 13 nominations
it's beautiful mendo gut um
that's awesome what we do in the shadows
outstanding comedy series
and the good place which is loves what
we do in the shadows
it's it's so much fun you watch it yeah
i should i should
you should i think you'd dig it um let's
see regina king
jeffrey wright um for westworld for
outstanding supporting actor
bradley whitford for the handmaid's tale
gene smart
giancarlo esposito and louis gossett jr
he deserves it he's fantastic in that
show
he was really really great yeah um and
what about the score
um i didn't they do [ __ ] like that they
do
it's that [ __ ] score i mean number
one if they win they got to get up on
stage and be like thank you john
carpenter
yeah because it sounds exactly like the
score
trent rezner and atticus ross did get
nominated for the watchmen score
as did i think ludwig goranson for
um the mandalorian ooh
[Music]
dun dun
um what else we got in the is that all
the emmy news that's all the emmy news
um quibby got 10 nominations
i'm just just saying it turns out know a
lot about quibby now
[Laughter]
this episode is brought to you by quibby
pretty much have you thought about it
well think about it again
you better think about it when slugfest
comes out you'll be missing out
um elsewhere in the news front did you
watch any of
the witcher on netflix i did not
oh my god the photo went right the [ __ ]
up
there he is wearing uh wearing [ __ ]
uh her wig from game of thrones
uh that's superman right henry cavill
cavill doing his best uh
gravelly superman voice um does he is
that what the character is
the witcher my name is gerald i mean
look he was a lovely superman but like i
loved him
in the tudors like he was henry's like
good friend with a conscience and he was
so [ __ ] charming and handsome and
[ __ ] sexy and [ __ ] i could see why
they were like come over here and take
your shirt off and be superman
but is his performance how is his
performance in this
it uh it it grow it growed on me it grew
on me
i started like i like the way he said it
better first time
that could go on a shirt right there
it growed on me what's what's the down
version
uh i i don't know
it growed on me i trued out nice
i mean it's very bridging tunnel but i
dig it
you're from becky's too man i true it
out yeah i tried two three times i
watched it but i don't [ __ ] know
i threw it out i threw it away um
it it grew like it grew
what was it it growed on me it growed on
me
yeah kid it growed on me no [ __ ] that's
high praise
you could see that put on a newspaper ad
like you know in quotes it growed on me
mark bernardi
it's not bad kid it growed on me mark
bernardin
100 rotten tomatoes um yeah like it it
starts out very one note very like oh
he's doing like
[ __ ] medieval times batman right
um but over over the course of the the
eight episodes
like there's a humor that gets shot
through that character which i wasn't
expecting
which makes it really fun to watch um
and it's
bonkers batshit crazy like there's all
kinds of men what's he doing like
killing
witches yeah it's like you know is he a
witch or is he killing witches
he's kind of a witch there's a whole
like
um like he's maybe descended from elves
who turned away from humans but then he
was somehow an outcast even among the
magic users and
so weird as much as i loved game of
thrones i'm like this doesn't interest
me
you know it's i sort of when i started
watching i'm like i don't know if i need
to learn the lore and
the rules of an entirely new fantasy
world
but after a while i just kind of you
went for it i went for it um it seems
well received
i've not seen anything bad about it it
did incredibly well
um when it launched on on netflix and it
already was picked up for a second
season and now they just picked it up
for a prequel
series because they're in the witcher
business will he be in that as well
um unclear but because i don't know how
long witchers
live for but it's set in an elven world
1200 years before the world of the
witchers oh so probably not him probably
not him
so he ain't gonna earn any more of that
sweet witch or money
no there's nobody's tossing a coin to
this witcher
but he gets another season he'll get
yeah and then it's netflix he'll
probably get another and then he's done
he'll be totally yeah it'll go three
three and three and out because that's
unknown unless you're stranger things
then they're like keep going that's fine
i particularly liked i mean tudors was
your way and for henry cavill i was a
man from uncle
yeah but that's even after superman so
you weren't in after man of steel still
you were like yeah i was like you know
he's not bad in man of steel at all i
mean it's tough to
chris reeve is we grew up with chris
reeve nobody's like please
let's not turn this into a battle of
[ __ ] superman you like who you like
that's great i think gamer cavill's
wonderful too
but we grew up with christopher reeve
christopher reeve was literally our
superman
and he did something with that part it
was
magical what he was able to pull off he
made you think he was two completely
different [ __ ] actors
yeah from clark kent to [ __ ] superman
just in his posture
just in his delivery for the first time
the glasses make sense
yeah good oh my god the only time that
should have been the tagline not like
you will believe a man can fly should
have been for the first time the glasses
make
sense
they might have made a few bucks on that
movie glasses they growed on me
mark bernardi
um but yeah man from uncle was my jam i
i still haven't seen that i think you'd
really like it ralph liked it too i
think yeah
like it i think for somebody who's
that's what i might do tonight you know
i mean this is the last week of my 40s i
never thought i'd say this but maybe
i'll get high and watch that movie
is it or is it another movie you're
gonna maybe watch and then ultimately
not
true that's true is this my jurassic
world i was lamenting before the show
that all i wanted to do today was watch
jurassic world
and i somehow couldn't get that
accomplished and i was made fun of for
my very first world problem
i can't get it done i just tried it just
can't get people like have you seen the
death toll i'm like i look i understand
of course
but it's about 150 000 people are dead
in america but i really wanted to watch
jurassic world
my parties are way out of whack but
still
it's my week damn it thank god we did
that off air
yeah no it's right out there now in
addition to slugfest which may or may
not be announced by quibby yeah i could
get dropped
i maybe scaramucci to myself out of that
job as well
like why did you talk about this i'm
like oh i didn't know i'm sorry
yeah i was [ __ ] good it's good like
i'm telling you i i'm gonna
i can't say it on it i'm gonna give you
a link and you're gonna be like who the
[ __ ]
what kind of mad genius decided to do
this
the clone saga dude eight minutes on the
clone saga with actors
reenacting it and you know what they
said they didn't like
you know it was supposed to be two-month
storyline
and the sales were so huge on the clone
saga they kept coming into the office be
like
keep it going keep it going keep going
so the clone saw going on for two and a
half years
oh my god but did you know it was
predicated on an old story
they did the clone like years ago in the
70s
i think jerry conway might have created
the
clone maybe i'm wrong maybe it's not
jerry conway but they did a spider-man
story that introduced a clone of peter
and his name was ben
reilly so they just for the clone saga
they're like
and it wasn't meant to be a saga it was
meant to be like for the clone
storyline for the clone arc yeah like
three issues
they were bringing him back to be like
oh that'd be [ __ ] weird right
and this you know they were looking for
anything in the wake of
of death of superman they were like we
need something huge
and this wasn't meant to be that but it
became
[ __ ] huge and then they got trapped
by it and then everyone started hating
it
so much and then they talked to the
writers and the writers admit at the end
they're like
i still don't know how we ended it they
weren't quite sure it's oh it's
wonderful all right back to the news
back to the news
um you remember the beginning of the
quarantine
when uh when trolls world tour
um made all the money with all the
[ __ ] money in
on vod and then at the same time
theaters were like this means whoa
yes with universal particularly amc was
particularly mad amc was particularly
chuffed
at this development i set you up
properly very nicely done thank you uh
you'd think it wasn't our first show
[Laughter]
uh amc was uh was uh was very put out
by this move and there was litigation
and they like went to court over it or
whatever court
they were talking about like this is it
we're never gonna show another universal
movie
right um they're probably sticking to
their guns right no
what huh you mean they changed course
they
they relented given that aamc is like
now kind of pulling themselves out of
bankruptcy and refi
configuring their debt because they
can't they can't afford to say no to
anybody can't afford to say no to nobody
particularly people that are like here's
the next jurassic and
this time it's jurassic world 5
fast 10. we're combining the two
franchises pretty much
we're gonna drive a [ __ ] corvette up
a dinosaur's ass
jurassic furious uh that would be great
can we do that what is it i would like
to see jurassic furious where they drive
a corvetta but
jurassic furious that is a good name
that's not bad jurassic furious
anyway see what it's more of that
cinderella [ __ ] you're giving away good
ideas
you could literally walk into universal
and pitch that and somebody might write
you a cheap check
good idea move along it's alright we'll
sign off in your valet parking thanks
for stopping by
for telling us how we can just mash up
the two franchises we already own but
still jurassic furious is kind of
brilliant i would watch it
i i look [ __ ] that i would watch it i've
never seen a fast movie
what oh my god did i say that out loud
yeah i've still never seen any of the
fast in the future
dude everybody says that andrew is going
oh you're missing out
everybody says that to me everybody's
even my friend malcolm was like
he's like i would never steer you wrong
he's going you like comic book movies
you have to like this he's going this is
just comic book movies with cars
dude fast five is the avengers
two years before the event just came out
it legit is it's
hey so you know you've seen all these
other movies and you've seen all these
other characters and hey here's this guy
from the the japanese version and he's
just stupid
i'm gonna watch a bunch of them before
that well you'd start with
one and then you'd move your way up to
like well the problem is i never started
with one in the first place because it
didn't really draw my attention
but you can now and i also hear that
like
one doesn't even come close to what it
became
no one one is one
is x-men to
dark phoenix like one is kind of a
superhero movie but it's just this kind
of like bromance between these two guys
one's a cop one's a criminal and they're
going for it
by the time you get to nine when they're
almost in outer space
you're like i don't know how we got from
there to here but i kind of enjoyed the
ride
really and so like nine and one are
almost a different species the same way
that like dark phoenix and the original
x-men
are like i guess the titles are similar
but i don't recognize any of these
people they're doing [ __ ] that doesn't
make sense but okay
i will say this yes if
if you weren't the busiest person in
show business i would say that there's
probably a podcast
in kev watches fast and the fears it's
only 10 episodes long
not even 9. you think i would be into it
that much
i i think for podcasts sake
i think it would be oh so there's a
chance that like i might watch and be
like
i knew it this sucks or you're saying
the podcast would be
like i [ __ ] can't believe that tom
felt that way like
i i think by by the time you get to fast
five and five six you will be all about
hashtag family
um in a way that you don't think you
would have been
in the first one is that right yeah
did you like point break the keanu
reeves patrick swayze point break yes
naturally fast and the furious is the
exact
same movie to the point that paul walker
speaks like keanu reeves for the entire
movie
it's the exact same movie as point break
only they're in cars
instead of on surfboards and then who's
the bad guy
uh vin diesel they're friends family
hashtag family
in the same way that patrick swayze is
the bad guy of point break he is the bad
guy
that's right but you love him because
he's [ __ ] patrick swayze i didn't i
look yeah i mean look i like patrick
swayze but [ __ ]
bodhi was he was bad news he killed
people he's a bank robber
yeah just because he surfed and had good
head of hair like
johnny utah was the hero never once was
i conflicted he's totally the hero yeah
and paul walker is totally the hero of
this movie
except that you also really like the bad
guys so they're friends
um well no the good guy sounds like the
batman and joker being friends it's
it's 21 jump street dude it's like i'm
going undercover in this gang of bad
dudes so who's undercover
paul walker and does does vin diesel
know that he's undercover
no that's the big betrayal by the end of
the movie by the end of which
the first movie he discovers like you're
a cop he's like yeah but i'm trying to
save your life dom
and then he went away he wasn't in a
movie or two
yeah he he vanishes because reasons and
so paul walker
um isn't even in two i don't know
walker's in two paul
which takes place in miami for whatever
reason but he's not in three that's
tokyo drift
and then three is all in tokyo and
nobody's in it yeah
so they're just using the name but lucas
black comes back later on
yeah everybody kind of everybody kind of
comes by episode
five everybody's back it's crazy and
then gadot gets introduced and this uh
like it just becomes like everybody
you've ever seen in a movie showing up
to do one last job
and then the rock shows up as like
you're kind of new bad guy but not
really because he's the rock and he's
never gonna really be a villain and he
wasn't in it from the beginning
no he's the new blood they inject
yeah that's like fast seven what did he
say fate of the furious
he what did he do he fingered a torpedo
he does yeah he's
it's in the trailer so i'm not giving
much away but he's he's riding
on they're on ice in this frozen lake up
in [ __ ]
i don't know canada slash russia and uh
and they're on this
this atv that's riding on the on the ice
and somebody shoots a torpedo
charlize throne is the bad guy in a
nuclear submarine shoots a torpedo
to hit this a this this you know
whatever suv
and then the rock's like just hold on
keep it going straight and he leans out
of the car i'm off the camera he leans
out
and he's like he just puts a hand on the
torpedo and then just like
pushes it into a different course and it
blows up another [ __ ] bad guy car
and it's it's it's amazing it's it's gi
it's the gi joe you never thought you
were ever gonna get and they spent 200
million dollars on each one of these
really
it's bananas like kurt russell shows up
yeah he's just in he just shows up jason
is in there
like it's kind of what you wish the
expendables
was yeah but was not and also
crazy gay the whole thing is
because dom toretto and paul walker's
whatever his name is i can't even
remember because he's so like vanilla
are in love for most of these movies
together and there's one movie when like
oh man paul walker's their girlfriend
dom's sister is pregnant
and they're like how did this happen
we're all wondering the same thing
because those two dudes are staring off
at a lot of sunsets together going
nice i love you dom it's like yeah i
know it's one last job and we get right
off into the sunset yeah baby
well then let's do it and then they hit
a big [ __ ] brazilian like
sheesh we gotta run more cars i guess
there's all these booty girls do we care
no never still
how can you be on the fence dude still
not sold still
i don't know what my problem is um i
feel like what was that other movie
with henry cavill man from uncle which
one should i watch
well listen if you if you've only got
two and a half hours yeah watch man from
uncle okay
if you're ready to change your life fast
and fear is because there's nine of
those
nine because you get and then gotta
watch hobbs and shaw fast and figures
presents
hobbs and shaw um which is amazing
did you ever read that new york times
article where they were going behind the
scenes in hobsonshaw
and it was basically uh contractually
required that neither of um
dwayne johnson or jason statham had more
or less time than each other on screen
like literally to the minute they had to
share the exact same amount of screen
time
to the point where dialogue was parsed
out to make sure they each had the same
number of lines and scenes
because nobody could win a scene there's
always got to be a snippy comeback from
like it was
literally script by lawyer why
egos wow yeah like if we're gonna do
this
then i'm not the second banana to that
guy it's like oh jason statham thinks
he's as big as the rock
is he if i'm but not paying attention
rock seems like he's the biggest movie
star in the world
brian johnson yeah but you know they
wanted both of them
and the way they get both of them was
all right
[ __ ] it we will litigate the script to
within an inch of its life
and it's still crazy fun um and i think
that's
probably just because of the goodwill of
the rock
right but it's insane that that's how
you make a movie that is kind of nuts
um all of that said yeah universal and
amc
um that's right we were telling the
story i thought we began our
past podcast series where you're trying
to convince me to watch the movie i'm
like it's not working
i know i feel like that's the whole
thing it's like i try to convince you
for 10 episodes to watch the movie
it's like a modern day green eggs and
ham
i will not watch fast and furious movie
i will not embark mark
i will i will not watch these movies
fast
you can sit up and kiss my ass
we got kids watching this show we though
yeah it's like 4 am in england
and those kids morning time they're
getting up for they have school over
there still they probably do because
they
don't have it here did they shut down
they shut down but yeah what again
uk did yeah no they figured it out and
so
you know germany sometimes it feels like
we're doing this show in a bunker
in america what's happening out here
hiding yeah like is there anybody out
there anybody at all do we have a uk
correspondent
what's that no um all right
the upshot of the universal amc battle
is is that traditionally the window
between theatrical release
and uh home video release four weeks or
so
it had been um around 90 days
85 days yeah way back in the day sure
you know
now at least between amc and universal
it's 17 days
it's three weekends so it's almost day
and date
almost eight 17 days away from a day and
date so it's
you know if so if you've ever had a day
and date movie come out you don't
feel bad anymore no not so much
everything's coming out day and day
practically
how is this playing with other studios
mark um they are
all petrified and i heard disney's
pissed cause he's like
[ __ ] you we're not like they didn't say
this but they were like
they sent mickey mouse over there yeah
[ __ ] you
this is [ __ ] they uh their point is
like
we we can get a lot more than 17 days
out of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] we make so don't throw us
into your [ __ ] stew
right 17 days stu so uh yeah i hear
they're
i read somewhere online not like i hear
from insiders i read in another article
online
that disney is they weren't pleased with
i mean none of the other
distributors have signed on to this
insane pact so right at this moment it's
just
universal and just amc but there's a
world in which
you know next year next april when fast
nine is supposed to come out
like hey it was out on april 3rd i could
also wait till april 20th and watch it
at home
and what that will and ultimately do to
the theatrical experience from an
economic perspective i mean the amc is
getting a a slice
yeah of the the premium vod rentals
because that was the only way they could
make that make sense for them
but like that's hundreds of millions of
dollars you're probably you're leaving
on the table
yeah so i could see that i didn't
release it's not the business i choose
to be in but i understand it and
i i you know i understand why
universal did what they did yeah it's
just everybody trying to figure out how
to [ __ ]
keep the lights on particularly now yeah
i mean it's a storm they're gonna have
to weather
and we're at the very least a year away
from anybody feeling comfortable to show
up in a theater on mass
in the way they would like you to for a
giant ass [ __ ] movie like jurassic
world three
yeah like listen we can't have theaters
filled 20 25
30 percent in order for us to make that
kind of bank yeah
but if we can you know that first
weekend third weekend charge people 30
bucks to watch it at home
all right you know like we're not gonna
make everything we wanted to make
we're making something during the
pandemic in 1918 there wasn't a movie
business yet was there
um no it was very nickelodeon based and
live shows theater and whatnot you were
still in vaudeville you were still in
you know so same thing must have
happened right all the live shows were
affected all the mass
gatherings were affected yeah i mean i
don't know how much radio drama there
was at the time
um that's true like we have podcasting
and that's been relatively unaffected by
like this outbreak it sounds like back
then they might have had radio and that
wouldn't have necessarily been affected
yeah
um thank you i mean i think zoom was a
difficult technology at the time
so not so many zooms were going on back
there not that many zooms
lots of lots of marconi's getting
together in there it's like hey
i can't talk i got to do homework with
my kid via zoom
that didn't happen in 1980 i don't think
so um so yeah that
that promises to continue to play out
and should it
spread amongst other distributors and
other other
sort of studios it could signal a
tectonic shift in the way we ingest
filmed media going forward and then
lucas and spielberg will be will be
right didn't they say some [ __ ] about
like this is it
this is the death of cinema yeah i mean
like every three years
they say this is the death of cinema
yeah there's the sky is falling
but this is the first time where it's
like hey they ain't kidding yeah this
ain't just the death of cinema this is
the death of a lot of things
they were they were bound to be right at
some point and so maybe this is it
um speaking of watching [ __ ] at home
yeah do you know every year there's the
the standard list of like the 10 most
pirated shows
um that are illegally downloaded off the
internet
um and you know every year it's you know
whatever i remember game of thrones
was for for us um
but by pirated they mean like these
people don't have an hbo subscription
correct they're torrenting it off the
internet
illegally without paying for it um and
so this year
that list was released and it's you know
a little interesting if only to
say here's what people are unwilling to
pay for during a pandemic
but also really want to watch let's hear
it um
number 10 harley quinn
the cartoon the cartoon um they don't
know where to watch it probably
yeah i mean like you know the d if you
had the dc universe app um you could
watch
there and h it showed up on hbo max but
there was no big campaign or commercial
going like go to hbo max to watch the
harley quinn cartoon
but i could kind of i'm not condoning it
but i could kind of understand
like it was a buzzy show that everyone
was talking about and you'd be like
where do you watch it and they're like
oh on this one app
right so it didn't clearly drive sales
to the app if only they had gotten the
sales
of how many people illegally downloaded
it totally
uh number nine agents of shield are you
serious
yeah that's a show that's like for free
on tv abc like all you need is actual
television yeah you don't even have to
download that show really and still
people are like so people are like i
gotta have it
and you know maybe it's international as
well
so they can watch it like day and date
as opposed to like watching it two weeks
behind
similarly the flash is number eight
wow i could see that again that seems to
be
like the times that i've done uh flash
and supergirl i think the american
episode
airs like a week at least before it does
overseas if not two weeks so
you know if you're deep into it and
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm current
with america then you know go to a
torrent site and you just
watch it that night yeah i can
understand that uh number seven
the mandalorian i can understand that
because not everybody has disney plus
yeah like i can understand that more
than i can understand the flash rates
i agreed agreed we're just like i don't
want to pay for that it's higher up the
list for that very reason
and it's a very buzzy show that
everyone's talked about and
if you felt like completely out of the
[ __ ] cultural loop if you didn't know
anything about baby yoda
so i could see a lot of people watching
that you know and especially again
during a pandemic
maybe people didn't want to break off
that extra eleven dollars a month can't
afford to right you know so they're like
super expensive but i guarantee you when
they get their jobs back and stuff
they like the mandalorian enough to
probably buy
disney plus when season two comes around
that's usually how it works
sometimes but if you know a victimless
crime
it's true you keep on going why should i
stop doing this now true
uh number six the 100 surprising
yeah they're fans i'm you know i i'm not
saying i don't understand it i'm just
not
i'm not that familiar with it but i've
seen a lot of people online talk about
it what number
uh that is number six i'm gonna put that
at ten if i was were you going from top
to bottom or bottom
top i'm going from ten to one so this is
number six
yeah yeah i would put that at ten if i
had to guess but good for them yeah
i mean bad for them but good for them at
the same time where is it air
um that's on the cw another cw show that
you could literally be watching like
five or six seasons in that many yeah
they're the new supernatural we're
getting some uh
comments in the chat that the cw shows
are very late
overseas that's what i know people are
watching
two weeks at least yeah yeah that makes
sense
i mean i remember that doctor who was
always a big pirated show because it
would air in the uk
before sometimes months before it
premiered
i actually thought about doing that with
i may destroy you because they were
i read that they're done yeah in england
and i was like oh [ __ ] i want to watch
the rest
um number five spongebob squarepants
why it's for free on tv oh nickelodeon's
part of cable it is
but like i have to think enough of that
[ __ ] is on youtube at this point oh yeah
um but yeah spongebob i guess they're
still making episodes of spongebob and i
guess people really
want to watch them or they're just
pirating the old episodes
yeah just like listen i'm high and i
want to go through the trouble of
touring and also how old is he now 20
years old
yeah so that's somebody's happy
childhood right
right now in this time you're looking
for some comfort you're like let's
just [ __ ] get lost in old [ __ ]
spongebob i want to see what sandy the
squirrel's up to
number four the walking dead
i would have put that like in more like
nine eight
good to know wow no walking dead is
still crazy still [ __ ] pulling in an
audience
uh just not paying for it not they don't
want it still pulling in that free
audience
as the as the ratings go down the piracy
goes up
i think that's their tagline for season
11.
damn true with it it growed on me
mark bernardin uh number three my hero
academia
wow yeah where is it air um i don't even
know i know some of it is on netflix it
might be on like crunchyroll or
something like that but
yeah crazy popular makes sense anime
yeah i mean that's got a massive
everybody too
[Music]
number two rick and morty i can
absolutely see that
um it's you know on
it's it's also number one tough to find
uh sometimes when it's not you know
airing
um but number two yeah it's a premium to
get it
especially if you want it without like
with the curses and [ __ ] right
um i and i tend to just buy the like the
itunes subscription so that i could
watch him
like forever and stuff on my time but i
believe that that show is absolutely
[ __ ] brilliant
it's one of my favorite things of the
last [ __ ] 10 years man it's so
smart so well done it's one of those
shows that almost makes you go like i
quit
i'm never gonna be this good uh and the
number one show
pornography now
that would make sense it would make
sense game of thrones still
still and this is just jiren the coven
this is just now this people still give
a [ __ ]
even though we all know what happens
what happens you know and part of me i
mean to be fair
it's a dubious honor hbo is just like we
yay and
yeah i mean it's still number one that's
money on the table but they've always
been incredibly proud of that fact hbo
would always say
we are the most pirated show on the
internet like finding a way to make a a
debit into a virtue it's true right you
get bragging rights you lose money might
as well take them bragging rights
seriously we got a lot of eyes on these
um but yeah part of me even like while i
look at this and say really
i do kind of want to re-watch the show
which one
game of thrones like because the first
four seasons now you just know when to
jump out yeah like hey
done i know what a certain point just go
like and they all live happily ever
after and don't watch the last season
i'll do the sweded version of my like
the 10 minute wrap up
just hey you know what it all worked out
what was the happiest season finale when
she was on her way with the dragons
across the narrow sea or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah the most optimistic
yeah whereas like [ __ ] might work out
she might be hey she might be queen
after all she may sit
on the ice [ __ ] yeah or that dragon may
burn it
i don't know we'll see but that would
never happen
yeah that's a little too on the nose no
uh
um all right the last story is less a
story
and more a here's a fun thing that i saw
on the internet okay
um you're familiar with the actor john
cryer
are you not absolutely it's ducky from
from pretty in pink he's lex luthor
from the cw berlanti verse yeah
um i met him when we were doing that um
crisis aftermath show he was one of the
lovely dudes super nice guy
um he went on a bit of a tweet thread
talking about
um when he auditioned for back to the
future he auditioned at one point to
play marty mcfly
are you serious yeah hold on
yeah that makes sense timeline wise yeah
he was having he was having a
conversation
with ben stiller who also auditioned to
play marty mcfly back in the day
and john started to talk about like the
back to the future script that i read
before my audition
was very different than what ended up on
screen
it opened with martin mcfly playing the
close encounters theme
on his electric guitar while he pirated
a vhs cassette of the movie
and the time machine wasn't a delorean
that had to travel at 88 miles per hour
and have 1.21 gigawatts of power
but just well a time machine that needed
nuclear fission and a secret ingredient
that turned out to be
coca-cola swear to god
the final sequence didn't involve a
clock tower or a lightning bolt but
instead finds marty sneaking onto his
atom bomb test site with his time
machine to be near the nuclear fission
that he needs for it to work
in an eerie scene he finds the test site
is complete with exquisitely detailed
suburban houses and mannequins to
simulate the effects of an atomic
explosion
on an american time oh my god it's the
opening of [ __ ]
he gets in the time machine and plays to
adam's getting the [ __ ] fridge
he's reaching out for the coca-cola the
countdown is set at 10 9-8 when he slips
and drops the bottle
it shatters on the ground he's all out
of coke he panics understandably but
then remembers he's in the 1950s and any
self-respecting american suburban home
has a bottle of coke in
the refrigerator are you kidding me he
checks and sure enough there's one in
there he pours it in the time machine
but then realizes
oh crap he has to find out how to
survive an atomic explosion again he
panics but then it dawns on him
there's a lead line box nearby otherwise
known as a refrigerator
he climbs in closes door behind him the
bomb goes off the time machine activates
and he's
simultaneously shot back to the future
does this sequence sound familiar to
anyone yes
i can hear you all collectively
screaming yes
it does clearly spielberg loved the
scene so much
he repurposed it decades later for a
much maligned scene in indiana jones in
the kingdom of the crystal skull oh
crier spilled some [ __ ] tea spilled
some tea
i guess he's never planning to work with
[ __ ] spielberg again
that that is some john peters loving a
giant spider [ __ ] right you ain't
kidding boy that guy
nursed a [ __ ] a real hard-on for that
scene for years so much so that he's
like
you know when we go back to indiana
jones i know exactly how to start this
[ __ ]
listen george i know you want to do this
daffy ass alien crystal skull [ __ ]
i'll come back and do it only if
george lucas is like i wanna i wanna
make a movie about
crystal skulls and spielberg's like hold
my beer
hold my coat
wow man [ __ ] good for cryer yeah
i guess you know after all that [ __ ]
two and a half men he must have a
a lot of [ __ ] you money to be like you
know who else is an [ __ ]
and start spilling all the [ __ ] tea
but it's not even like
you know who's an [ __ ] it's just
here's how it was almost
yeah here's how they feel but also it's
a deep insight
into steven spielberg yeah and what he
thought
was a good idea that he pulled forward
there there is an old saying that we
probably shouldn't use anymore because i
bet it's all kinds of insensitive
but it had been used in writer's rooms
all the time okay use every part of the
buffalo
yes you know which is hey you know you
wrote some script at some point and you
loved it but it never went
but here's an idea that you can maybe
refashion and here's a bit you can
retrofit into here and here's something
you can
adapt into here clearly steven was like
you know what
man i always [ __ ] love that you know
what i was getting a little
judgy and it's ironic because i was just
earlier talking about how i'm working on
green hornet
for like the fourth time in my life so
you know what good for him good for him
for like
going i'm gonna let this waste this is a
cool idea dude never fridge during a
nuclear blast that's going to [ __ ]
play yeah i mean
it might not have played in the 80s but
it'll play in the arts
what do you mean they didn't like it
did they like the prairie dog in the
beginning coming out of the they didn't
like that
yeah it's like you mean it's become the
jump the shark
[Laughter]
well you know what he he knew that it
would be culturally important
he just didn't know in which direction
so that's not the first time spielberg's
done that with indiana jones either
he stole something else in or reused
he reused in yeah in raiders of the lost
ark the scene where tote comes in and
and the hanger hangs the hanger was used
in 1941
and fell flat in 1941 and he thought it
was such a great
bit he reused it in raiders of the lost
ark and everybody loves it and remembers
it in raiders
that's why i [ __ ] love this show that
is an awesome [ __ ] story man
wow two bites at that apple for
spielberg's two bites you know and
how we perceive it from the outside is
oh he's just a genius who could do no
wrong but it's like no
he he self-corrects yeah you know or
even the greatest of us self-corrects
yeah like there's there's a podcast that
i've been listening to well
when i was listening to podcasts and
cars called good one
it's about jokes and comedians that i
think vulture puts out
and uh and one of the steady questions
on this on the podcast is
what's one joke that you know is funny
even if an audience never laughed at it
and then asked him comedians like you
know what
that one like i love that joke and here
then they would tell the joke and you
know it's for the audience to agree
whether or not it was actually good or
not
but this feels like that thing was like
what gag did you know was great
that nobody will let you put in a movie
it's like let me tell you about this
[ __ ] fridge
or you know what [ __ ] kill what i
thought would have killed in the
audience
right over their heads nazi make it
yourself hanger
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god i thought it was the most
funny thing but like [ __ ] we had to
cut it out in 1941 because audiences are
[ __ ] but i'm putting it in raiders
maybe the problem is it wasn't funny
enough to be in a comedy but it's
perfectly funny enough to be in an
excellent point it was probably the
lamest joke in a comedy
like full of that john belushi in it but
a very strong joke
in a movie that's not meant to be funny
but but yeah when i saw that thread i
kind of fell in love with it
because you know i just love that [ __ ]
like just digging up stories about the
things we almost got and we dodged
bullets on
let me tell you something man cryer has
a lot
of [ __ ] stories i would imagine he
was there ground zero two when [ __ ]
charlie sheen was like
winning all that stuff man i mean hell
he was at ground zero for the brat pack
yeah that's right all of those [ __ ]
stories
i bet you lived through every [ __ ]
error he's like the forrest gump of this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um is that all the news that is all the
news mark gave you the news give it up
for mark we can't hear you but i'm sure
you're doing it
all right it's five in the morning in
the uk let's get to some q a
uh you got some questions for us there
jc jcr owns this here establishments
coming villainy
cantina uh and closes it very graciously
for us to come in here so we don't have
to fight the crowds
um jay-z screaming hordes yes there's
always here
uh what do we got what do they want to
know what can we tell them uh let's see
chris de silvestro wants to know
uh if you guys could work with
lin-manuel miranda
on an existing ip what would you
choose to make a musical about with him
wow um
how about uh how about this speaking of
like
second bite at the apple me
and lin manuel doing a remake
of the 19 late 70s early 80s movie
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
band wow
beatles songs so they you know his job's
already done for him and [ __ ]
so he doesn't have to write new lyrics
um listen man this is just you cash a
check you don't have to worry pretty
much man but just with a fresh face on
it's good story could have worked
a lot of people [ __ ] on it and like bgs
peter frampton
[ __ ] that george burns [ __ ] it billy
preston is the weathervane what the [ __ ]
it's a great movie i love it um is it
jukebox musical
those are popular these days mark so i
would say
me and lynn doing a jukebox the jukebox
jukebox musical the jukebox musical [ __ ]
em hi
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
band the the movie not the
you know the beatles classic but the
movie that was based on the entire
beatles catalog
um okay see where i went i see where you
went where are you gonna go
um i have one
no they did a musical they did an addams
family musical already right they did
all right so not that one bb newworth
played morticia that's right
so and nathan lane played uh gomez
um i would do
[Music]
i would do flash gordon
[Music]
with music with music songs songs i mean
you've got all the [ __ ] awesome
queens same kind of art direction though
oh it's got to be daffy and crazy and
shiny and everything's made of like
lava lamps and i mean badly hanged vault
hands flying in like it's already
kind of a shitty musical um but i love
it to death
and so i think that would be a blast and
i also
i think there's probably a really good
musical of christine
about the car about the demon car
it was a musical movie yeah not a
broadway show
who wants to look at a car on stage what
is this [ __ ] high school production
of grease
you'd take me to a christine musical
movie you got my money
i got your money you try to take me a
theater to watch a car on the stage
i say [ __ ] you we'll go to my driveway
and do the same thing
but the cars are meant to be moving mark
not sitting on a stage i think you could
do some some starlight express [ __ ] with
this
oh my god remember that [ __ ]
man roller skates we need skaters of
species we lived on the east coast so we
were fed those commercials for like
[ __ ] years where they tried
desperately tried to make that a thing
yes and there were people who went who
were like it's spellbinding and [ __ ] but
like
you know i always i lived for it wasn't
cats
let's say that it wasn't now and forever
it was like 15 minutes and gone
but i i used to it was there for about
two scaramucci's and then
[Laughter]
they used to have the uh the commercials
for the broadway shows which was always
testimonials from rando people standing
in front of a brick wall with the poster
of the player we had such a good time
i'd see it twice more times yes i'm in
from pomona and it was amazing
ramona um
so yeah i would do i think that that
[ __ ] demon car
and teenager with like crazy libido who
likes a girl and wants a car
like they're all [ __ ]
i hate all these [ __ ] you're a demon
behind the wheel
but you understand me christy
uh but with more rap oh good point it's
lim manuel
that's true there's gotta be some
interesting you know i don't know why am
i writing lyrics i'm embarrassed now
he'll be writing them lyrics all right
all right that's a good question
question two
uh this one's from adrian pink adrian
adrian pink adrian pink it's a hot name
uh they would like to
right there uh if you could make a
season of 24
and base it around a superhero who would
it be and what would be the story
so it would have to be like minute for
minute like 24 hours
and we get a whole season of this and
you get yeah you've got 24
hours to make it to tell a story to tell
that story story with those characters
batman hands down minute by minute
batman and i'm in charge of the show
sorry i'm looking at jc minute by minute
batman i'm in charge of the show
[ __ ] man you kidding me you do the
entire rogues gallery
maybe twice in one season um
and what's more interesting the batman
[ __ ] jack bauer man i'd much rather
watch batman do the same [ __ ] in a mask
um jack bauer he could have my loyalty
if he would just put on a [ __ ] cow on
a cape but he didn't
so batman 24 fox
uh the following i'll do you one better
batman 24 7. it'd be a 24 hours and a
week-long
show yeah my mentor and he also opens a
convenience store
batman store 24-7
enough there's a robot clerk which turns
evil batman has to take it out
we got a lot of time to fill uh i would
do
the last day on krypton i would do the
24 hours before the planet [ __ ] that's
good
that's good we know what's coming we
know what's coming the iceberg's coming
but we don't know any of the [ __ ] that
happens before that jorel through
jarrell's perspective from gerald's
perspective or maybe from
from mom's perspective or maybe laura
[ __ ] no jorel do it through jurassic
world
both the parents let's just say through
through the l's
through the house to the house of l yeah
one big l one big l
well they all they all held on that
fateful day
um that's a good [ __ ] call man i like
that i'll watch your show you know what
i think i have a few bucks in my pocket
yeah i'm going to donate to your cause
you have quibby money
yeah i might have somebody money on me
that's a quibby series right there man
or like we could probably go to hbo max
tomorrow and be like hey you know we
want to do
20 remember 24 they're like we don't own
that we're like all right well then
forget it
yeah how about the last days of krypton
yeah and it takes place over the course
of 24 hours so each episode
is in house it's an hour they're like
that sounds like 24 i'm like i thought
it's
not it's not it's maybe this
idea is not for warner brothers they're
like it's only for warner brothers
maybe it's gerald torturing a lot of
people to get information about how to
fuel a spaceship and maybe we'll just
take this idea across the street to
marvel they're like
good luck um i like that man
[ __ ] was that the second question that's
the second question what if you did
24 but it was 24 minutes yeah but each
minute was an hour and you did it
as the flash moving super fast
go back to us that's a good idea
yeah he's running at a different pace
and [ __ ] but wait
so the rest of us are as statues does he
get to unfreeze from time to time
or is he everyone he deals with
otherwise he's a solo act
everyone he deals with is
would have to be in time with him and
within the speed force to some degree
can he bring people with him otherwise
we got no dialogue yeah he'd have
serious
monologues where he's like i'm alone i
can't run fast enough
run barry run run superman could show up
you should be in charge it's a good idea
that's true superman can pop in
that's smart i would also maybe do uh
24 starring chewbacca on cloud city as
he's trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
happened
like who's here what are these
stormtroopers doing here what's
happening where'd c3bo go
that's right and where he gets shitty
with the ugg nuts and whatnot
and they torture him too they tortured
[ __ ] chewie and like does he go in
and
eat the dinner that darth vader laid out
after they get taken away
that that is all i honestly feel like
sooner or later somebody's gonna [ __ ]
do it right and i hope it's jon favreau
but like
that [ __ ] dinner has always captured
my imagination well and he's hungry in
return of the jedi and gets him into
trouble so you know he always thinks
with his stomach chewy [ __ ] chewy of it
all just the fascinating [ __ ] fact
that darth vader is gonna sit down at
dinner with him
and sooner or later take his helmet off
to eat and they're gonna be like
what the [ __ ] oh my god
now i'm not hungry yeah put the helmet
back on put it on
um or you know it's darth vader in the
mass and he's just put the straw to his
still just the idea of like did they
have a conversation did he lay out his
villain plan
for them did they sit there quietly i
would just like the the
shot of vader just breathing heavily in
a straw slowly
from the bottom sounds like a [ __ ]
bonk
um i always i've loved that [ __ ] it's
one of my favorite moments in star wars
history just for
the doors open you stay see
darth vader and han solo's first
instinct is to
[ __ ] shoot him oh i love that that is
like
[ __ ] it's you know i remember i think
we talked about on smartcast years ago
but i was like
and this was pre the death of osama bin
laden but that's like his reaction was
like
the doors open and there was osama bin
laden and he was like oh my
like i've got a chance um what a
drawdown on vader
it's [ __ ] insane man and and just so
like
uh like what if he what if he hit him
like imagine if he [ __ ] like star wars
ends in the middle of empire strikes
back
if han solo [ __ ] gets a shot in and
baby's like
holy [ __ ] storytelling remember what was
that movie uh [ __ ] uh oh
kiss kiss bang bang spoilers at the end
one [ __ ] uh what's his name from l.a
law
corbin bernsen corbin berenson is going
to shoot robert down in june he shoots
at first he goes
[ __ ] magic cat no that's a [ __ ]
captain
magic oh that movie's so [ __ ] good
is it now you like that movie kiss kiss
yeah i dig it
where is that compared to the fast and
furious movies
it's better than the fast and furious
movies well the
yeah i mean the first the first fast and
furious movie is a just it's a [ __ ]
cop
undercover cop drama right like not
badass somehow it morphs into
somehow it becomes a [ __ ] superhero
extravaganza
but i think that that kiska's bang bang
i love that movie
is better technically than any of them
right but if here's what it is
if kiss kiss bang bang was actually
a prequel to iron man yes which it is
and then you get to avengers you're like
oh [ __ ] i didn't think that's where this
was going right i didn't think the dude
would be in [ __ ]
space but okay that's about the
trajectory
of fast one two let's save that for my
50s
we do when we i hit my 50s which as we
know isn't that far away yeah
i i've been told with r reliable as
associated
i've heard i mean comicbook.com can
quote me on this
i believe my birthday is very soon um i
i'll do that in my 50s man
and then we should record podcasts about
it um but i think
prior to my 50. like now prior to my 50s
dude you're like four days left
i know i gotta pick i gotta pick
carefully these are the last movies in
my 40s man
but you're making me want to watch kiss
kiss bang bang again
i like how this conversation is made you
want to watch everything butt fast
i'm just trying to avoid it like the
plague i'm like i better watch some old
[ __ ] first
like i've gotten this far without
watching i'm not gonna start now but
kiss kiss bang bang is so amazing
i was selling somebody on wag the dog oh
josh and liv i was like
you guys haven't seen wag the dog i mean
they've been moving years
it's [ __ ] good it's so good and right
now
it's finger on the pulse
crazy [ __ ] good relevant um all right
third question third and final takes us
home
and there are two [ __ ] good questions
that
preceded it so three better be better be
hot
[ __ ] on toast jc particularly
topical for the show uh the best
birthday gift
you guys ever received and the one you
wanted but never got
oh i don't know i didn't i never really
fetishized my birthday
as a kid and i still don't know i you
know
my family makes fun of me because you
know the first thing i think about when
it comes to my birthday is like oh
that's a marketable
event like we could totally sell tickets
to something and they're like
what do you want to do and i'm like
that's it like i have a hard time
my kid has a hard time understanding
that you know she's like what do you do
for fun dad you never do anything for
fun and i'm like
i do kevin smith all day long everything
is funnest [ __ ] thing in the world
um but um i you know
when it comes to gifts that i didn't get
and gifts that i did get it won't be
birthday can i go with christmas instead
the gift that i didn't get for christmas
uh when i was
five or six six years old was i wanted
the migo bat cave
now mind you i didn't even have the migo
batman doll i assumed i'd get that as
well
what kind of cruel parent gives you a
bad cave with no dolls to play with just
this haunted bathroom
i thought it was like i'd get the one
gift and a backdoor second gift you know
i was planning ahead and [ __ ]
but we were not uh wealthy people
whatsoever
i would also like a backdoor second gift
that was the gift my father was looking
for that christmas a little back door
from my mother yeah
bat cave plato's retreat either way you
get the back door second again he's like
it's christmas grace come on
the boy's getting the bad game what is
the man getting
um my mom god bless her it's not quite
gift of the magi but like you know my
mom
was like well he wants a bat cave and
the migo bat cave was way
way way too expensive uh my father was
making like
you know 70s poor he was making 70s
government sell
salary and it wasn't a lot um
so they christmas comes and i
don't know that i'm not getting the back
cave i
i i'm it's hinted that santa might be
bringing me a batcave so i'm
thinking i'm getting the [ __ ] amigo
back here this is gonna be crazy
and then i open up one of my gifts on
christmas morning and it is a
it is a bat cave um and it's
like uh kind of uh plastic
uh it's got a handle on the front of it
is like
wayne museum and then on the back side
is like the batcave
you open it up and there are you know
paper
dolls that stick in little plastic
cylinders so they can stand up and um
very very
um you know
well a bat cave is better than nobeck
but it was the first time like i
realized oh we're like we're poor
like it's that simple and i was raised
pretty
like well by my parents and politely and
[ __ ] so i was
i never said that to him where i'm like
you're poor but
like why are we poor yeah why is this
happening to me
where's our wealth um but uh
but yeah it was kind of bittersweet and
i do actually do have a
i have another [ __ ] here but you know
what
the question was what did i ever get a
birthday gift that i was my favorite
birthday gift
the one that kept on giving i do have an
answer for that i was going to tell a
sad story about when my dad
i wanted a bmx bike so badly and my
father uh built me one out of an
old bike but in order you know to
like bmx we had an old [ __ ] you know
old-timey bike and [ __ ]
he took like a metal not even a huffy
like
i wanted a huffy we had like [ __ ] you
know a girl bike with a banana a schwinn
seat and [ __ ]
so he you know remember like bmx bikes
had the metal bar across the middle and
she did a little puffy uh
he got a little piece of [ __ ] tin
tube
and then chicken wired it between the
yes now that of course but as a kid i
was like
my mom was like your dad's been working
on your bike for like a week you're
gonna love it
[ __ ] and they opened the garage and it
was you know like homer's car
like when homer built his dream car in
the simpsons it's just so like
you know [ __ ] oh my god like it was
bad enough riding this bike before
now he's just you know blinged it up in
1979
with like you know some chicken wire and
[ __ ] and
now i would give you every penny that i
have to get that bike
to have that [ __ ] bike because it was
made with
incredible [ __ ] love and affection
you know and made by a guy who was like
i can't give him what he wants but maybe
i could get [ __ ] close
he didn't but he left an indelible mark
on my heart that [ __ ] bike
i i wish i could get that bike again um
but anyway
the birthday gift i always wanted and i
did get and it was my favorite one and
it changed my life as well
was a smith corona word processor
got a smith corona word processor when i
was a kid i
we had an electric typewriter a smith
crown electric typewriter and they sold
this additional package that came with
like there were no computers yet i guess
there was an apple computer an early
lisa or something
so you had a drive that you put a disk
into a floppy disk
and that connected to the typewriter and
the typewriter the electric typewriter
was your keyboard
this drive you could save the work and
then there was a monitor like a green
dot matrix monitor that you were looking
at the word essentially
word processing before microsoft came
along and stuff
and then when you want to print it out
you put
paper into the electric typewriter as
you would and then press the start key
and then it
typed like a ghost was typing and it
took
five minutes per page to type it out but
it you know that was me my parents
you know put some money into it it was
like probably 175 bucks or something
back then which was a lot for us
and that you know of course i was loved
writing and i wanted to be a writer and
stuff so
number one it was great for that but
number two like
it was not just here's a [ __ ] pen and
paper go right it was like here's
you know kind of cutting edge technology
we're not gonna buy a computer because
[ __ ] that but like here's something that
you can save your work
i wrote [ __ ] clerks on that i wrote
everything on that for [ __ ] years
that was my training ground and stuff
um so that that was hands down i think
the best birthday gift i ever got i also
got a laserdisc player once
that was pretty cool what about you um
the present that i wanted and got
i must have been like eight years old
and i wanted a green machine do you
remember green machines
oh i was too fat for a green machine
i was too chubby as a kid for a green
machine plus that was a rich kid's toy
i mean that was a like you know parents
are working overtime to get the toys i
mean look
you know most kids were lucky to get a
big wheel but a green machine
yeah that was like a big wheel plus a
delorean to like a big
tesla of big wheels cause it it steered
from the back and had two handles and
had two handles it was like a [ __ ]
tank
yeah still have to pedal it but you
still have to pedal it because
you know nobody's putting motors and
should also have the amazing name the
green machine
machine so like i had a big wheel that i
literally rode so much
that it went from because the big wheel
up front which is where your feet were
um was made of plastic yeah and if you
do it enough you basically wear the
plastic down so instead of having one
tire you had like two records
right
got the green machine and i then
proceeded to almost kill myself with it
because when i was a kid we were living
in the bronx and we were on this street
that was uh we were perpendicular and
there was a big
hill on the other side of the street so
it was no place for a green machine
every street was like just this [ __ ]
terrace of do
of doom and so you'd like pull your bike
up or
you'd huff your goddamn green machine to
the top of the hill
and then just tear down and then try and
turn
into your street and this is [ __ ]
asphalt pavement
doing like at least twenty twenty five
minutes like [ __ ] like you know
bus speeds yeah but you can't stop for
any
railroad crossings and so i try to make
that turn
into my street and there's no rubber
anywhere on a green machine it is just
plastic hard plastic
hard [ __ ] plastic and so you know 30
miles an hour trying to make this turn
and i i think i might have actually
turned a degree before just traction
was a myth and then i just started
spinning
down this hill just
until and they were because for some
reason in the bronx and this part of it
there were woods um i but it was more
like just a patch of non-developed land
at the bottom of this hill
right and i just like and then hit the
lip
of the curb and then went airborne and
managed to miss every tree in there
and then just land him in the dirt you
are so lucky yes with a busted green
machine like the damn
you're lucky that you got a green
machine
oh my god your parents must've loved you
yeah you're lucky you didn't [ __ ] die
could you imagine all the neighbors just
going like he's gonna die
watching you spin down the hill you know
just watching me climb it up there like
oh don't do that yeah like this ain't
gonna go well
get some popcorn yeah like somebody you
should get his parents now oh they're
both at work oh baby you're going to die
[Laughter]
so that was the best one i ever got um
it lasted about a day
and uh and then the one that i wanted
and never got
was the um the millennium falcon
action figure holder like the collecting
case case that was shaped like a
millennium pilot
falcon and did you have the darth vader
collector case the c3po collector case i
had the vader collector case but i'm
like you know whatever's [ __ ] vader i
want the falcon
yeah and i think the fact that i had the
vader case
made it that i was never going to get
the falcons oh because they were like
you already got
you got a [ __ ] case already yeah
we're not rich like we got green machine
money
like you got the case he's like but i
have more figures now it's like well you
got a bag
put the [ __ ] figures in a bag why do
you need a special case i know
yeah i remember that i remember my mom
being like here's a bag from foodtown
put the figures in there
i'm like ma no that's not how this goes
i had two
i never got the c-3po case but i had two
darth vader
figurehead collector cases because like
one barely fit
the collection like you needed more
space more than one do you remember the
original
collector case which wasn't even shaped
like a thing it was just like a box
nylon or you know that yeah it's just a
box with two trays
but once they started making it in the
shape of things like i still have my
darth vader collector case yeah
no i mine never showed up apparently
santa
at the workshop just couldn't make that
[ __ ] happen never got your millennium
falcon i never got another falcon and
like because then you could [ __ ] play
with the falcons
you could it's a double thing it's a
double thing and that was my logic
because i always had to like make a case
for why i wanted something yeah like
it's a two in one it's a twofer like you
always want me to clean my room this
will help me clean my room i put all my
[ __ ] toys in here
and then i get to play with it and
you're always like why is he watching so
much tv it's a floor cleaner it's a toy
it's a floyd cleaner it's a toy i'm
doing this for you mom yes
i'm trying to make your life easier i
remember trying to convince my dad to
buy me a copy of mad magazine that had
king kong in it they did king kong that
issue
because it also had a parody of network
and i knew he wanted to see that i was
like dad they've got
nut work nut work you wanted to see it
i guess if he was like oh they're doing
network are they well here's 60 cents
here you go kid for your humor in a
weathered vein uh so yeah those though
that that's my present
narrative all i take from all of that is
you were rich enough to own a green
machine
i look i looked up to kids like you and
childhood
then again i lived in the bronx and that
like the riverdale
shiny ass part of the bronx you're like
oh is that a body
wait riverdale isn't like there's a
riverdale
there's a riverdale in the that wasn't
but it's not the riverdale this is not
meant to be like where archie isn't sure
no i don't think so so that's just
anywhere usa right riverdale usa they
never
identified it like no this is riverdale
missouri [ __ ] right like
springfield it's
just its own world and [ __ ] amorphous
place
um i think for a second there i was like
you just [ __ ] shattered my mind was
riverdale's in the bronx was it
originally was it based on the bronx
i mean i don't know where the people who
created archie are from
right but it wouldn't surprise me that
they're from new york because everybody
who made every comic book ever was from
new york
for the first 40 years of it and so like
yeah no that could be a dude who grew up
just outside of there i think they
mentioned
like riverdale in 25th hour
spike lee movie like because i think she
goes to school
yeah up there it's a ritzy part of town
is it really yeah
and she was wearing a uniform it's like
a private school kind of thing
that'll do it i love that movie um and
before we go
um there is another beloved pop culture
icon who was celebrating our birthday
who
bugs bunny 80 years old 80 years old man
yeah also from the bronx oh my god a
true
new yorker um you know that uh it was
the other day that it was the 80th
anniversary of the very first bugs bunny
short hence bugs bunny's 80th birthday
and
naturally twitter blew up so there was
lots of
you know gifts of some moments that i
haven't
thought about in a while but were are
burned into my [ __ ] brain from
childhood because we saw them
so many times we didn't have options
when we were kids they were like
here's the looney tunes show we're gonna
play it all week you're eventually next
week you'll see the same
episodes because even though they made a
bunch you know sooner or later you're
seeing reruns and [ __ ] like that but it
didn't matter because
everything bugs bunny did was just so
heroic to a child because he stood up
to everybody he was the little guy who
[ __ ]
was the smartest guy in the room didn't
matter if there was a giant wrestler
or a [ __ ] some big opera singer or a
dude with guns
or hunter yeah yeah or [ __ ]
uh a monster um frankenstein
like he was just always the quickest one
like i
there was a line in uh rick and morty
this season
where he's like uh what you're doing is
called negging and your generation
didn't invent it it was invented by bugs
bunny
um i realized in looking at a lot of
those clips how much
of my sensibility and my character
came from watching bugs bunny like
you know it's he's incredibly
influential
um and you know now of course he like
they're doing
new animated shorts on
hbo which i checked out and they were
like oh [ __ ] it's like them
just you know [ __ ] made for tv
doesn't have quite the
doesn't have the cinematic 24 frame
animation
which all the the looney tunes cartoons
had because they were [ __ ] movie
shorts they played in movie theaters and
stuff
so you know bugs bunny's always been
with us but like i didn't really give it
a deep think until his birthday where i
was like
so much of like what i do what i write
about
my characters the things even
particularly right now we're doing sun
and lockdown
very looney tunes inspired more than
anything else
so yeah he was and i loved chuck jones
the work of chuck jones i went to see
bugs bunny on broadway
wow not on broadway it was at the garden
state arts center so i don't know if
that counts
but you know same thing they played
because this was years ago in the like
80s
they played cartoons and then had an
orchestra
play along something that like now is
fairly commonplace they do it the
hollywood bowl or did
all the time before the covet and stuff
but this was so
new they were like we're [ __ ] playing
bugs bunny cartoons with a goddamn
orchestra playing in front of it and
people like that's
classy and [ __ ] um but yeah i i i love
bugs bunny way more than most
animated characters i was never a mickey
mouse guy i was very much a bugs bunny
guy
yeah i mean me too and i think some of
it is i feel like disney was
the dc and warner brothers cartoons
marvel you are so [ __ ] damn right you
know and like i
liked dc fine but marvel
always felt like no that's the real
world that's the world that i grew up in
it's
that i could find the baxter building if
i wanted to because i give an address
on a street that's actually exists in
manhattan and bugs bunny was a [ __ ]
upstart kid from the bronx i mean that's
what mel blanc said that he patterned
the voice after
and that sense of whatever it is i can
handle it
you know whatever the problem i'll find
a way through it you know and i'm i'm
never going to lose but i'm also kind of
never really going to win
you know i'll always persevere like
that's what it was like whatever your
problem was
i could find a way out of it i can
rescue a stalemate from the jaws of
defeat
and transgressive like all the looney
tunes cartoons felt like
as a kid as you watch them you were
getting away with something like violent
and i'm not saying cartoons should be
violent but like
disney didn't do transgressive disney
did beautiful lyrical
you know fun goofy if you will
but looney tunes like did
the people's comedy you know it felt
like they were doing shakespeare and
shakespeare
when they did shakespeare was for like
everybody
for the common people not for the royals
and [ __ ] like that looney tunes always
felt that way
wasn't it awesome that remember the
[ __ ] the dogs you know cartoon where
the dogs come after them and they're all
piled up and they line up and [ __ ] and
one of them opens them like a gate and
steps through
bugs at the end of an alley and he picks
up a book to
protect himself and all the dogs go
running away and he looks at the book
and it says a tree grows in brooklyn
[Laughter]
i just remember like asking my parents
like i don't why
why did they that book and then my dad
being like because
dogs pee on trees and it was like even
the simple understanding of
oh there it is like
i learned i didn't learn that dogs pee
on trees by looking at it in the natural
world
i learned because bugs bunny taught me
you know yeah
no it is it is an indelible creation
you know made with crazy speed
you know like they were pumping out
those cartoons at an incredible rate
and there's a stretch there's like 15
years where like it's chuck jones and
for his feeling and michael maltese
wrote like almost
all of them you know just going to town
and
and and building your childhood and
exploding
the form of the art itself and some of
that stuff is as
um avant-garde and as as progressive as
anything that would come from the french
new wave that anything that would come
out of any of the movies you know they
were heavily influenced by stuff
um going all the way back to german
expressionism and then
it's in a [ __ ] kids cartoon yeah i
mean the
some of us i mean they very famously
said it on seinfeld where she was like
everything you know about
culture comes from bugs bunny cartoons
um
you know we we we most of us are of our
age got our first sample of opera
via bugs bunny what's oprah duck and and
rabbit of seville
like crazy man like but they weren't
playing for us
they made those cartoons for like our
parents in some cases
yeah you know or like we talked about in
the beginning of the of the show
that it was stuff that a kid could like
but it was
so layered and deep and came from a
place
of pure expression that anybody could
find something in it
and that's what great animation can be
in a way in a way that almost
not to say that no other form can but
it is so free with its own rules yeah
and
so elastic with what it can achieve that
it's the thing that makes
the most sense to hit every audience at
once i saw
a tweet a lot of tweets appreciating
bugs as one of the
uh first like
as a as a transgender icon
because he was gender fluid gender fluid
he would dress up
almost like every third cartoon like
he's wearing his hands and
and remember like uh you know i think it
was wayne and garth
in uh wayne's world or one of the
sketches they were talking about
garth was just like when bugs bernie
just slept like a girl
it makes me feel funny in the pants
like it was it was like when you were a
kid and you watched him whenever he did
dress up like a girl you're like
i couldn't i could see being married to
that yeah
convincing yeah and like i remember and
some of those cartoons there was one i
don't know why it just popped into my
head
but it was the the short fat guy and the
tall skinny guy marooned on an island
yeah and they're just literally like
thinking about cannibalism it's like you
know
i'm gonna eat that dude like you know
what let me eat that dude too and then
bugs bunny shows up it's like let's eat
the bunny
yeah it's a cartoon about cannibalism
you guys for kids yes and it ends with
them looking at each other seeing meat
and chasing each other down the beach
yeah
the implication is when these credits
are over one of these men is going to
eat the other man
but that ain't bugs bunny's problem nope
happy birthday bugs indeed thank you for
everything yeah really it's also another
famous fictional character's 40th
birthday hold on let's think
after on the 31st
on july 31st fictional character 40
years
40 years old harry potter it's harry
potter's 40th birthday he's going to
turn 40 tomorrow
right i also am plugging my 12 live
stream there we go
there we go i knew there was a real
master the other penny drops if you will
but yeah chooses the wizard as it seems
it is harry's 40th birthday though what
are you guys doing for it
uh you can do drive up potions we have
all little test tubes where you can mix
your own
drinks and uh we're gonna do a 12-hour
livestream so we have
um one of the weasley boys coming on
to chat we have uh dan fogler's coming
on to chat oh [ __ ] hey
um some really good podcasts uh
we're giving away a bunch of sideshow
collectibles and funko pop
stuff what day is this tomorrow tomorrow
so
starting in nine hours nine hours the
live stream begins
and they could drive up and get potions
potions class alcoholic potions get
some of that polly juice [ __ ] hell yeah
that's [ __ ] dope man you want to
celebrate
harry potter's birthday tomorrow you can
jump online
where is it at the uh your stream uh on
our twitch page our youtube and our
facebook
and also we partnered with mugglenet who
is like the biggest
non-official harry potter so you can
watch it on mugglenet also
[ __ ] night or if you're here in town
drive up get yourself some liquor
it's always a good idea lick her in a
car
drive through booze emporium um
there it is folks we're as as a better
man than both of us once said that's all
folks that's all folks
um did you have a good time ladies and
gentlemen did you learn a thing or two i
know i did and i learned that i'm not
going to watch those fast and furious
movies until i get into my 50s until i'm
until i'm an old man until i've lived
half
a century tuesday yes it's
coming very soon tonight what are the
things i was talking about watching
man from uncle man from uncle what was
that andrew
kiss kiss bang bang yeah i'm probably
gonna wind up watching that again
i know i watched that a couple times a
year it's so [ __ ] good
val kilmer is great in that too you know
what i just rewatched this week
and [ __ ] can't like get enough of
the magruber movie do you ever see it i
i haven't seen all of it it is
[ __ ] legit hysterical yeah he i'm
telling you it's worth your time
he is he is [ __ ] brilliant will forte
i love will forte there was just
something about that movie that
go for it there's i know i'm with you i
had a bias
and one day i saw a scene and i was like
that was funny and i was like i'll give
it a shot
it's [ __ ] fantastic cry i cried so
hard i laughed so hard i cried during
one scene
i'll i'll tell you what i'll do okay
i'll watch mcgruber and what do i watch
fast and the furious no that's too many
of those there's only one mcgruber
you got to trade me a one-for-one like
you watch mcgruber i'll watch a man from
uncle
okay all right they're aggregate films
kind of the same movie when you think
about it like white guys running jeffy
there's there it is all right so you'll
watch magruber [ __ ] hysterical
and i will watch uh man from and we'll
report back here next week
next week with our feelings same fat
time same thing oh we're not there yet
we're not yet because we still have to
sing happy birthday
to whom to you i don't need no song yeah
you do
know what i need money buy a ticket
to the kevin smith live stream 50
questions 50 years of streaming with
kevin smith
uh i don't know where i think it's you
go to smallcast.com for tickets
sing me a song at sixpence [ __ ] i want
your money yeah i don't need your wishes
well wishes i need your cash
somebody was like why are you charging
for this and i was like
we gotta we gotta pay some bills man
birthday what what is that like what
version are you singing that's the
stevie wonder black version of happy
birthday oh
that was your stevie wonder no because i
can't do stevie wonder fair enough
that was my like drunk teddy pentagrams
version that was you
yeah yeah i think you paint this off
shake it down you got you got you got
what i need
you got what i want oh my god that was
good not bad right yeah well you did
have band work didn't you weren't you in
a band i was the lead singer of a band
you were a singer
that was not very good hit it again here
like no [ __ ]
try to give your best teddy just that
line
but uh top volume as if we were in ten
thousand person arena
okay watch your ears everybody
you got you got you got what i want
that's pretty [ __ ] good man you got
you got you got what i need
my only criticism bringing that mic
closer to you
i think that's what they're looking for
when you're doing teddy pedographs you
got to blow their minds
and i got to blow their backs out
[Laughter]
because it's teddy uh it comes from the
diaphragm you got you cut
when do you turn 50 uh i will be
49 in november so i got you by a year
got me about a year and change i get to
be a 50 an astronaut i can tell you what
it's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe save you a trip if you don't want
to go when it's time to the undiscovered
country
[Laughter]
oh i might want to watch that too every
time we do this show
like when i go home the other week i did
go watch the mist and i was really
[ __ ] sad
because it was like two in the morning
by the time it ended and i was like
[ __ ] man that's that that movie hits
hard
um but i think i think i don't know i
just watched kiss kiss bang bang but now
i'm like i'm just remember the end of
the movie like when they do like the ps
that was almost shot on video
and it happens after the scene with val
kilmer where he comes in and he [ __ ]
like
belts her father in bed and [ __ ] and
he's like
yeah he's like what are you hitting a
poor man he's like yeah poor you and
[ __ ]
and then he leaves and you're like what
a [ __ ] weird ending then they have
this little ps where robert downey jr is
just talking to like
the live stream camera or whatever like
that and he's like uh
how about that scene with the old man he
goes right that was kind of harsh
and he goes [ __ ] him he's creepy
oh i'm watching that movie i just
figured but i will watch
decision made yes decision [ __ ] made
i will watch um
um i keep wanting to say a man for all
seasons man from uncle man from uncle
directed by the guy richie
guy ritchie oh he always does something
entertaining did you see his aladdin or
no
um i did see his aladdin and
uh it's fine was it a whole new world it
was not though
that that is the next t-shirt it was not
though
that's your review show right there i
wanted to love it i went in ready to
love it i was ready to embrace it
it was not though and then when you
liked it instead
it growed on it it growed on me it was
not though
two snaps in a circle um i'm watching it
you make sure you watch mcgruber i will
everybody out there watching macgruber
that's my homework kind of hoping that
they get a sequel like way later
they're gonna tv show what yeah the
peacock they're doing them a gruber tv
show
are you [ __ ] why isn't this in the
news because it's six months old
dude is that right it's when is that
happening
soon i bet you they would wrap
production already happy [ __ ]
birthday to me oh my god finally [ __ ]
something i'm into
is getting second life that's [ __ ]
useful news that's something to look
forward to
we gotta beat this covent mcgruber's
coming man it's something to watch
um right on [ __ ] that well that's a
good reason to rewatch magruder there
you go
good times good luck knowing it's half
the battle it's gonna it's gonna be him
though
oh yeah do you think kristen wiig will
come back i would
not be surprised if she did seriously
yeah i mean i don't know how much she's
gonna be in it but
[ __ ] this is making me so happy
like the sad thing is like you know uh
[ __ ] people are watching this and
like oh he really likes this idea
and then tomorrow morning it'll be like
kevin smith died in a car accident his
way home from the scum villain and
cantina
and people will be like he really wanted
to see that mcgruber show
what a [ __ ] bummer for him man if
that happens kids
i lived a good life and i've enjoyed
magruber and you know what i'll watch
the new one from heaven
if there is such a thing and if not i'll
watch it straight from hell
i made dogma so i'm pretty sure that's
where i'm headed i betcha of the two
hell has a streaming plan that's true
heaven's like read a book yeah and hell
they're just like
you can watch uh crackle
and that's not a judgment on crackle i'm
just saying no but it totally is
like we have nothing but quibby sir i'm
like quimby well that's a fine product
you know they got a show that i like
very much on it cause it's life fest
coming soon
uh there it is man did you have a good
time if you did
it's because mark pulled that [ __ ]
news particularly that green hornet
story man
give it up for mark bernard yeah that
was a tough find but uh
but i tracked it down good fine good
story good ink
uh there it is uh folks come back next
week
probably do it friday night again this
week we did it on thursday
next week we might do it on friday back
to fridays next week we might do it on
saturday [ __ ] you we'll let you know
when it's gonna happen
where are you going to be yeah we have
nobia exactly
watch us because we're on there you go
uh thanks for hanging out with us for
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard
tune in next time same fat time same
fat channel spodcast.com or you got you
got you got some
gas i've come it growed on me it growed
on me
you